[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i do
along what club
hey man i'm kevin smith and if you're
like me you love
oral and you love hours of it pulled
long like taffy right man well i got
lots of world because i've been
recording podcasts
since 2007. it's time to take the gloves
off ladies and gentlemen
and let you have a crack at it by
joining that kevin smith club there's
four
tiers you just want to hear my voice be
a clerk you want to hear my voice and
see me be a mall rat you want to get
some merchandise like pins
or scripts be a fun employee or a yoga
hoser
it's a place where we're going to park
the entire smart dive man
all that shit's not exclusive enough we
got three more shows that are
only gonna be going on at that kevin
smith club the return
of plus one the marital podcast that i
did with jennifer for years
wake and bake with kev that's right a
video show where every morning whatever
i'm doing while i'm smoking man you're
gonna hang out with me and then of
course
the exclusive kev cast man that's the
podcast of me just by myself
or i just kind of do my own self therapy
while you listen
then there's video we got hundreds of
hours of unseen video
are you even supposed to be here today
well find out by paying five bucks a
month to become a clerk
get you access to ad-free podcasts plus
it lets you join that kevin smith club
discuss board man where
once a month we're gonna have a big old
gathering now for 10 bucks a month man
you could be a mall rat what do you get
for being a mall rat
you get all the video shows man all the
video and the video archiving we got
hundreds of hours of stuff
that you're going to be able to watch
for 15 bucks little man
you can be a fun employee in that kevin
smith club
you'll get everything the clerk gets
everything the mall rat gets
plus you get four pins a year man they
said i was crazy for making yoga hosers
so guess what our highest level
is the yoga hoser for thirty dollars you
get everything the clerk gets
everything the mall rat gets everything
the fun employee gets plus
four times a year we're going to send
you an exclusive
mini script that's right look at this
script man this is the clerk script from
second draft january 1st 1993
pen and ink revision man we're making a
copy of this
you're going to be able to have one but
if you can't join that kevin smith club
don't worry about it spodcast
hollywood babylon fat man beyond they'll
all still be free from now until the end
of time
but if you want to be involved in the
least exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club man now's your chance
to club
kevin smith
oh welcome to another episode
of fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm
mark bernardi
hey oh i'll be honest with you i've been
reading the chat
getting roasted for that long ass
commercial i'm not gonna i ain't
throwing anybody under the bus kids but
there is a
more compact version of that kevin smith
club commercial where i fellate the mic
but uh jc got blossom slipped in the
snyder cut version of that spot
just longer longer and stronger
every shot was in there and [ __ ] like
but
i did appreciate like the a lot everyone
going well i guess it's pride month
in the in the comment section based on
me
fellating a microphone um welcome back
kids uh we took last week off
um selfishly but we're back
we are the greater good the public good
discussing
all the [ __ ] things that matter and
let's be honest
sweet tooth holy [ __ ] have you watched
this sweet tooth yet
not yet it only dropped yesterday
well i'm on it i'm on episode six
it was tough to walk away to come do
this i'll be honest holy [ __ ]
it's one of those programs where you're
like why
why do i bother why am i trying to be in
the same business
uh we'll talk about that uh in a bit but
[ __ ]
magical um let's
speaking of magic mark yes uh you know a
lot of people
uh especially the younger generation
these uh gen
z kids mark they assume this [ __ ] this
happens for free right they're just used
to getting free on the internet well
somebody's got to pay mark
the bill comes due bill always comes to
the bill always comes to yes we're
no different than others man we gotta
sing for our supper and stuff
and we're delighted that somebody
provides us with supper
that we can eat and then regurgitate to
y'all like baby birds into your mouth
the metaphor went real awry mark no but
i dig it it was it was a long ride but i
think it was worth it
point i'm getting that we got a
wonderful sponsor this week kids
uh a sponsor that's making all of this
possible because if there was no sponsor
me and mark we don't get out of bed for
the requisite
thousand dollars of you know per ad that
one gets on the internet
me and mark have a rule there's a
ceiling and a floor
and that's where we live right between
the two of them and [ __ ]
so uh we thank the good folks at
manscaped
god knoweth how there are this many
hairy bushed
men in the world but manscape continues
to
uh advertise with us here on fat man
beyond they
are this episode's uh of uh
at least the first half sponsor of fat
man beyond
um manscape i'll be honest with you mark
i literally saw a tweet from somebody
this week who's like just
ordered the manscape to a box you guys
are effective
so there are people out there who are
taking this seriously
people who are hearing about having the
needs to shear
the sheep that they're keeping between
their legs kids as i speak
follow along manscaped.com that's where
we want you to go
manscape.com because when you do that
you're gonna get off
20 20 on free shipping at manscape.com
when you use the code fatman20 man don't
forget
uh that it's father's day coming up man
don't forget that you came
from your dad's balls for heaven's sakes
a very salient point
and a very what is it a
seminal point indeed as we disseminate
more information
well [ __ ] man coming with those jokes
mark
uh this year show your original home
some love with manscape the idea is here
it's father's day kids father's day is
just around the corner
and your dad's nuts are just between his
legs man you probably need a gift
for a very hairy dad make your dad proud
this year
and get him and yourself while you're
out there in in the making well and it's
been a process
manscape manscape lawnmower kids
4.0 that's right this is like an old
carson commercial where they can
actually bring out the product
when larry sanders showed you the garden
weasel uh look at this
sleek ass box man
you think we're done we're not done
there's a whole other level of this [ __ ]
let's open it up wang okay this is fresh
out the barks
barks fresh out the box mark let's see
if i was on the run i needed to
shear my nuts like [ __ ] fast
and i just unboxed this bad boy with a
flip on
let's see
nice do you hear that that's the sound
of a of
her and his satisfaction mark
vibrating trademark that is manscaped
man
i love that you're pitching the
lawnmower 4.0 as like getaway disguise
gear you're on the run you're in a gas
station bathroom you've got to be
another person does it come with a
charge and the first thing you need to
do
is shave your balls that's where they
look
oh ball hair is like a fingerprint kids
they can track you down with that
it comes with all sorts of cool [ __ ] man
there's a charger that you can stick
that bad boy into
it's got different heads so you know in
case you're like i don't want to lose at
all i want to keep a nice layer i want
to look like don
johnson back to your miami vice i want
my balls to look don
johnson cool yeah i want my balls to
look like a marine
high and tight comes
with i guess a little bag oh with a
plug-in you need that right sooner or
later this bad boy is
gonna need energy but not now i opened
up that box
i've had that box for two weeks and
she's ready to go mark
that's that's the good folks at manscape
because they know
the moment you decide you know what [ __ ]
it is time to
shave my nuts you got to do it then
you can't give yourself time to think
twice and be like i've gone this far
[ __ ] not when they got technology
it's [ __ ] sweet kids
tell them what they're missing mark they
are missing
and [ __ ] like the upgraded trimmer
includes a multi-function on off switch
that can engage a travel lock it's a
great feature of dead
can i just take a polish to like we're
it's a little weird that we're talking a
lot about my dad's balls but
yeah all right let's let's just lay into
it
um the wireless charging system uses
electromagnetic induction which can help
battery length last
longer so if you got to trim the bush
coming out of here did the horse shack
between your dad's legs
or the bush coming out of his nose the
lawnmower 4.0 can handle it
oh he's doing it look at him he's doing
it i'll give a [ __ ]
good enough for my face good enough for
my nuts
i'm a damn man if i really want to freak
people out i just start shaving the
beard off man
like one time i had to take the beard
off for richard kelly because i was in
southland tales and then
put prosthetics on my face and i came
home the next morning and the kid
like screamed and cried man like i went
like this and then i was like hi
and i had no facial hair and she'd only
ever seen me with facial hair
so she freaked the [ __ ] out and whatnot
that's how you know that the clark can't
eyeglasses this guy's
legit works which is you just take one
thing off a dude's face
and he's a completely different person
sidebar my friend andy mcelfirst who i
do education with we all know and love
andy
and he pointed out today we were having
a discussion about something scarlett
pimpernell
in the dumas novel he does he changed
his appearance with a mask or is he
literally just put the
the dimple mark yeah i mean because
that's the thing he does the beauty mark
is what separates him from his other
identity but
does he put on a mask is he technically
like the first costumed avenger he does
have a dual identity
he does i don't know well no dumas was
writing in like
the mid-1800s and i'm not entirely sure
when zoro
was written or the first sort of folk
tales about zorro
hey banff boy boy we could use a little
[ __ ] producing around here
[Music]
he's looking at him
i saw him skittering at his [ __ ]
keyboard i gotta pull up that cool
cartoon
i'm glad you did uh bamf boy do us a
favor
look up scarlett pimpernell and zoro and
see which one came first
meantime we'll finish up our ad man the
good folks at manscape ladies and
gentlemen
they're they're there for your nuts and
you like you saw
you could use it on a face mark uses it
on his head
yeah look how look how [ __ ] fresh and
so clean my head is
man shear your skull shear your scrotum
take two of them both ladies and
gentlemen with manscape i
showed you the lawnmower 4.0 what
[ __ ] more do you want man you're not
convinced
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code fat fatman20
at manscaped.com man that's 20
off for free shipping at manscape.com
and use the word
uh the code fatman20
all together at once we thank good folks
at manscaped uh
for for uh having the
the shorn balls to sponsor this [ __ ]
show sheer brilliance
i mean god what a what an age of wonder
we live in where a we can have a show
of our own we're nobody really in charge
with the exception of
[ __ ] banff boy who can pull us off
the air he's kind of like the head of
the network for us
but not only that but like when it comes
time to pay the bills like you know
walter cronkite and [ __ ] when he was
doing the news he was like what is the
commercial for
god damn it i'm a [ __ ] you know like it
was probably stuff
he had to follow or even [ __ ] like
read for that he was like oh
we get to read for cool [ __ ] like this
is a product that
shaves your balls it's so on brand
yeah good folks at manscape totally
cronkite's covering ford galaxy
the brand new four-door sedan from the
good folks at ford
take care of a place to place in style
and will i keep your balls clean
clean your bows that's [ __ ]
interesting but believable right there
hellis um all right man how are you
little information here real quick uh
scarlett
pimpernell is 1905.
zorro 1919
these were the the books i i the the
zorro one like
makes more sense to me i would have
thought [ __ ] like
alexander dumas was earlier than that or
later i don't think dumas did scarlet
pimpernell
i think um it was
written by baroness orzzy
a lady published in 1905
after her stage play of the same name
enjoyed a long run in london
having opened in 1903. wait so she
created the character of the scarlet
pimper now
um she created the
the book and the play welcome to
wikipedia beyond i'm
how fast can jc read [ __ ] for me
um is that true i know what it says
alexander dumas did the three musketeers
so i'm probably confusing the two
actually you know what i'm just
regurgitating false information that
andy fed me today he said dumas
that dumbass the uh the movie
also beat zoro well sort of beat zoro
the tv movie of the scarlet pimpernel
was
1982 the uh
antonio banderas zoro was 1998
even though there was the 1957 zorro
as well and the 19 i want to say like 81
zero the gay blade oh
with uh george hamilton indeed a lot of
uh kids of the 70s and 80s their first
exposure
uh mine for sure because not only is he
done
de la vega the dashing young uh
california nobleman he's also
bunny wigglesworth his uh his
distance it's a cousin i don't think
it's his twin brother i think it's like
a cousin who when don diego
like breaks his leg but california needs
a zorro
he calls on his cousin bunny
wigglesworth to fill in
and uh adventures ensue
delightfully colorful adventures ensue
happy pride month you guys
could yeah a movie that only some people
could make today
it could definitely be made but i doubt
the people who made it then
are the people that could make it today
if yeah
yeah it's it's a it's a very
tight [ __ ] needle you gotta
but it could be rebooted and it should
be rebooted by you know like a gay
director to gay cast like because it was
a fun concept and a fun movie
yeah and you know george hamilton can
still be
like uh the bad guy because he's
something yeah somewhere in the
background
um the uh uh the scarlet pimper now
is not to be confused with uh daffy
duck's scarlet
pumpernickel if i remember correctly was
he the one or was it sylvester was this
no i think it was definitely so wait
bamfoy
do us a good service here man like
did the lady who who's the lady who
created scarlet pimpernell
uh the baroness or z o
r c z y and it's
literally read us the top of her entry
does it say like she created this
character
um let's see uh
oh baroness emma or z uh
she let's see
hungarian-born british novelist and
playwright
best known for her series of novels
featuring the scarlet pimpernole
the alter ego of sir percy blakeny a
wealthy english
fop who turns into a quick thinking
escape artist
but wait she he a wealthy fop aka bruce
wayne turns into what
uh a quick thinking escape artist in
order to save french aristocrats from
madame guillotine during the french
revolution establishing
the hero with a secret identity in pop
culture
it's right there on wikipedia it must be
true that's the first one then
right like that's the first dual
identity
and it was created by a lady what's this
lady's name who's been
unsung uh baroness
emma or z uh
book name
wow man that's pretty hot why aren't we
making that movie
[ __ ] all this all these other day jobs
we got let's go make a documentary about
her
and get her life rights then we do the
biopic as well
the lady who created batman kinda that's
how we sell it i mean maybe that title
is long
i'd like to see that in the spine of the
blue ring believe you created batman
kinda
i would like this warner brothers uh
reaction to the whole affair as well
but that's nuts they don't teach that
i've never heard that before
[ __ ] you know what kids you come to fat
man beyond
to learn [ __ ] right you know middle-aged
dudes discover some
[ __ ] and and they're like you know we
are nowhere
nowhere nobody is ever near the caliber
of something as important as like
watchmen uh exposing like most of the
world to
the tulsa massacre having never heard of
it prior to that
but i would like to think mark tonight
we expose some people to the fact that a
lady created the
archetype upon which all of the
fandom toxicity is based indeed the
founding principle of superhero dem
is the secret identity a very concept
created
by a turn of the century writer named
emma orsi
uh i just hope that all the comic book
websites that normally
pull stories from us pull that story
mark
into like bro that's an old story it's
on wikipedia it's part of
history i didn't know it though that's
crazy to me
not crazy like how could it be a woman
could never do these things but
how couldn't like it's never come up
before it's just never
never occurred to me the archetype for
and where's she was f
hungarian banff man banff man if i call
you bam bam will you get in here quicker
apparently not um
let's see uh
so hungarian born but does that mean she
might have been born there and then come
to him
and then moved yeah that's what it seems
who published those books because that
sounds very fresh i mean it's set during
the french revolution
initial publication uh
oh it says it was the original play was
produced and adapted and opened october
15 1903
um who published the book
i don't have a publisher there's a lot
of them though
there's a scarlet pimpernole
and then i will repay in 1906. the
elusive pimpernole in 1908.
el dorado in 19 this is this is like the
mcu
we could go here and roll for 20 years
is that right what they got a lot of
characters
there's just uh one two three four five
six seven
eight nine ten eleven books
two short story collections there's a
lot
if they got a scarlet pimper now they're
definitely going to have like the
[ __ ] yellow pimpernell the evil
no dude there's a whole league of the
scarlet pimpernell
that had 19 different members in it
so like zorro passes the mantle down
or she's got a he's got a [ __ ] super
team
of like sir andrew falks is the second
in command lord anthony dewhurst lord
edward hastings lord john bathurst
lord stonemaries sir edward mckenzie
the lord saying denise sir richard but
all
all being all of them having held the
title of scarlet pimpernell
um it's unclear or it's just like the
[ __ ] avengers like there's your one
captain america and then there's like 15
other people who are helping
do the work of the pimpernell because
you know this [ __ ] is
uh what is it called public domain right
like probably
we can have our we could build a pimp a
pumpernickel universe
mark tasty pumpernickel
whole wheat we got some sourdough get
all the breads in
and we'll make all the breads um yeah
man somebody should be jumping on this
pimpernell
[ __ ] we are now going to have jc pull
the last 10 minutes out of this podcast
and we just say the scroll of pimpernell
that was cool right
yeah hey kids you didn't hear anything
that's crazy man like [ __ ] i would at
least like to see
a documentary about that about uh the
woman one one more time
the baroness ultimate horsey
horsey the baroness horsey
that [ __ ] if that don't sound like a
comic book name right there
i mean she invented the league of
extraordinary gentlemen
120 years ago wow
and the justice league and just the
archetype of somebody
putting on a mask and [ __ ] like doing
it
wow but when when was um
somebody pointed out targets they said
boohoo
iii in chat said tarzan was 1914 not so
dissimilar
um he doesn't wear a costume yeah
i would and he doesn't really have a
dual identity yes he has another name
and as much as he wasn't named born with
the name tarzan his little lord grace
stoke or whatever [ __ ] but like
it's not like he's like you know i call
myself tarzan so that
they don't know at the zoo that i'm the
protector of elephants like it's just
who he is
so he's and he's a hero i guess but like
i don't think of him as a superhero you
not really not really um phantom of the
opera um
was sorry tell this is gonna be one of
those three hour shows we haven't even
[ __ ] started and we're like
you think tarzan's a superhero i don't
know
it's like no there's no secret identity
he's just always [ __ ] tarzan
and you know what kids if you think
tarzan is a superhero
tarzan is a superhero except i have a
very
limited view of what superheroes are
sometimes and that
generally involves costumes and capes
but
it takes all kinds even you know
the dude who is tarzan i mean what i'm
like
i mean he's jungle batman right what is
it
he's like jungle batman yeah he is i
mean thank you well well once you put it
into that terms
cool again for me don't go batman holy
[ __ ]
why aren't we [ __ ] go look him up bam
man maybe we can make a movie about him
as well
this charlotte paper you what about
tarzan isn't he public domain yet
um probably
will have a claim to tarzan in some
fashion because of their movie
um but yeah i mean phantom of the apple
wears a mask which is the only reason i
brought him up
yeah but you don't count he's just a bad
guy
a man he's a villain like that's a
super villain story isn't it yeah
um yeah the first tarzan is 1912.
falling down the rabbit hole of whether
or not [ __ ] tarzan counts
he counts the scarlet pippernell's
capture in my
imagination the baroness
or z or z that part i can't remember
just the baroness just hold on to the
baroness yeah the baroness
and her first name was emma though
that's kind of cool i'm a frost i
probably will go out in the future and
be like the baroness emma frost
created people building this [ __ ]
dumbass
can't believe he does a show um
all right let's uh let's how you doing
what are you up to i have been uh well
this week
was let's see on thursday
i did a bunch of uh press
like uh press junket for
um a little show that you and i are
familiar with
entitled masters of the universe
revelation
yes so uh we shot some stuff shot some a
lot of social stuff to feed up into the
streams and whatnot
some like cool breakdowns of the scenes
and stuff
and then i did a bunch of press for
honestly
you see it started four hours of prep
like a bunch of one-on-ones but then
also round tables
and um it went longer we were supposed
to be done at three and we went to like
six i think
but that's because you know not because
a bunch of people were like let me tell
you how much this
[ __ ] blows you know it's easy to sit
there for hours and do press because
the enthusiasm was was enormous like i
it was wonderful um it's being received
i'm not supposed to talk about [ __ ] but
oh my god like it's
working the way i hoped um so that was
absolutely
lovely and so people are going to start
seeing a lot of that
stuff this week particularly
now people have seen some images from
our masters universe show
uh but this week pay attention
to uh netflix netflix jesus i'm gonna
get fired
netflix geeked ladies and gentlemen uh
because it's geeked week
and they're gonna show a bunch of [ __ ]
man like i they showed in their little
preview grid all the shows that they're
gonna
do stuff for um one of them sandman
which like i was like the [ __ ] already
like holy [ __ ] so who knows what we're
going to see there
i know what we're going to see from
masters yeah
it is phenomenal mark's seen it too
good time so that's this week for
netflix uh
geeked uh get ready if you're
if you care about this motu stuff we all
the cool kids called motu
masters of the universe revelation uh
keep an eye out this week because this
one's gonna get geeked
netflix geeked um not a sponsor just
friends
um so i did a bunch of press for that
and uh put plans in place
for uh we're gonna open up our smod
castle back in new jersey that's in the
same building
as uh you know the quick stop in
leonardo
because i'm gonna be looks like i'm to
be uh back
east for most of the summer and uh in
new jersey
and so uh we i did some planning for
that and whatnot
and i tried to get out to see a quiet
place too
because i heard so many great things
about it and about like from people who
were like i went to see it in the
theater
the first time in over a year um and so
i was
getting pumped to do that but we never
quite made it out there
um but then it was like all about
sweet tooth which is
just beautiful it's you know remember
when uh
where the wild things are trailer came
out and you were like
this is gonna be the greatest film ever
made and [ __ ] and it was insanely well
done but like you know the trailer was
[ __ ] absolutely genius uh this
this like when i saw the trailer for
this it like broke my heart and [ __ ]
and then i was like ah we'll see
it is beautiful poetic lyrical
um it's i like i don't know who it's for
but it's definitely for me
um i hope i hope kids be smart enough to
get into it like kids
kids um i'm not saying like kids are
dumb but it's just like it is
you know it's i think it plays
more heart-achingly beautiful for the
older you are because it's kind of a
story of childhood as well
and an adventure and um and you know
learning
finding watching the world open up in
front of you losing your parents
i'm gonna get [ __ ] emotional talking
about i've been crying
for hours watching this beautiful show
that made me
doubt myself as a [ __ ] entertainer um
the kid's great everybody in the cast
great the guy who plays big man is great
the girl who plays bear is great it's so
i never read
jeff lemire's comic book and i'm almost
glad that i didn't because like
it's a complete [ __ ] discovery this
netflix version of it
um but holy [ __ ] how wonderfully
inventive and yet familiar at the same
time you know it's not like we're
you know holy [ __ ] i've never seen
anything like this but you haven't seen
anything like it at the same time
it takes a lot of pieces of our
childhood and kind of stitches them
together there are elements of like
peter pan of course and with the lost
boys when he
comes across this community of uh
you know these kids that are like you
know [ __ ] dumb with adults and
you know are there for the hybrids it
comes down to as we've seen in the
trailer a zillion times like
uh it's crazy like pressure i don't know
when they started shooting this [ __ ]
but there's
so much about the the virus
and the quarantine and people wearing
masks and like
it's pain as you're watching it going
like wait a second this has been going
on for the last year
they had to have started shooting this
prior
to the quarantine and maybe when
quarantine kind of loosened up they
leaned into it more because there's at
one point
he rides a horse into town one of the
characters the doctor and he hitches the
horse to a post
and there's a sign that says like you
must remain six feet apart
and you get this like [ __ ] creep in
your chest where you're like
is this like oh my god man and then you
realize like
again i don't know if they did it in the
source material but like
jeff lemire's book's been out for a
while dc comic book
um it's one of the best things to come
out of dc
in a long time like not saying like
everything else they do is crap but it
is
top-notch right out you know out the
door like
elevates their game something they
haven't
like done before you know what i'm
saying i'm not saying they're used to
doing the same thing over and over again
you know we have to be very careful how
we talk around here mark
i'm just saying this is a new shade that
they're showing us
uh and and uh heretofore unseen
but you can do more of this there's so
many titles
in you know the dc house that aren't
necessarily just
superhero oriented and stuff remember
they had vertigo for years and years
so netflix god bless him seems to be
raiding
you know dc for all the [ __ ] stuff
that i i don't know why this wouldn't
have been on like hbo max maybe they
started making it or made a deal before
hbo max existed but
because it's a warner brothers show they
got the warner brothers shield right up
front
each and every time but you know now
netflix has that and netflix also has
sandman
two shows were like you know big dc
comic books and
two comic book properties that are
incredibly different than than dc
is known for here to for on the you know
cinematically or
or even like in the world of their
streaming and stuff so
beautiful elegy pam to youth um
we're peeing if you like um very uh
moving and i got three episodes left so
when we're done doing this
that's what i'm going to be doing
watching all the sweet tooth and ball of
mazza
i um i have no idea where it's going if
it's one season only
if they'll do it again but like robert
downey jr and his wife are producers on
it
it's perfection give it a give a spin
kids it's so
imaginative and so beautiful so
beautifully shot
[ __ ] incredibly shot uh
you know i don't know where they did
most of it but big wide open spaces and
you know
the story about the collapse of things
as we're kind of
we've seen before like there are
elements of it that call to mind the
walking dead and stuff
like oh my god the whole world has
collapsed but i've never
quite seen this version of a societal
collapse story that's
also filled with so much hope and wonder
at the same time
i think the guy who plays the bad guy to
the the general or whatever
was the dude the actor who was in my one
of my episodes of the flash who played
the thinker
showed up in the last two episodes i
watched but it's
fantastic stuff i i hope like kids get
into this
i don't i don't know like i have no idea
like i know my kid would get into it but
she's like i'm gonna be 22 this month
right i wonder if a five six year old
would watch this and be
captured by it i you know i hope so i
know
honestly that i would have when i was
age six sorry cotton because i was like
a soft kid
i was like he's a soft boy um
and then they said he's getting softer
and then they said he's a round boy
so i i went for [ __ ] like this at a
young age i was
nostalgic and sentimental before i was
old enough to know what those words
meant
but i'm curious like i gotta ask some
people with kids if they
if the kids get into it because it's so
like i didn't know how to describe it
but jennifer was going like what is this
is a kid's show and i'm like well it's
got a kid in it so
you would think it's a kid's show but
you know it's it's got is dealing with
some headier
issues and heartier issues than you know
the average kid show
but maybe i'm wrong maybe kids are more
grown up at this point but [ __ ]
wonderful absolutely wonderful so i
think i think you'll dig it
yeah i can't wait i gotta hear what you
think it's i think it's very special
one of those that's gonna get a bunch of
award nominations if not when as well
yeah i mean i i i when you said we
talked about the trailer when it dropped
i feel like a month and a half ago or so
they did they went early which was a
sign of them being like we like this we
believe
yeah um so it just dropped on friday
which is the only reason i've been able
to get into it yet
but i can't wait i can't wait
um what did you watch you watched modoc
um i watched the first episode of modoc
i still got some more catching up to do
but
um it's fun you know it's a it's a
stupid buddy show
from the seth green animation house and
so it has a lot of the same rhythms of
like you know robot chicken and
weird digressions and lots and lots of
jokes it's a joke machine
patent oswald is perfect as as modoc
i mean it's silly it's all get out but
there's a little story in there there's
a little relationship spine to it
but it's you know it's it is not the
grandest thing in the world but it's
also not trying to be
um it's trying to be just you know 25
minutes of a good time and i will
happily take 25 minutes of a good time
i will smoke my uh cbd
cigarette to that mark there you go
um i watched a couple of episodes i'm
trying to parse them out but lucifer
dropped the second half of its fifth
season on the netflix
are you are you a devil worshiper i am a
100 percent satanist
um when it comes to my content
don't say that they're going to take
that out of content and put that
all over the internet yeah well not
comicbook.com they usually write nice
things but somebody
av club is going to write like [ __ ]
uh smith's buddies of satan his [ __ ]
figures
like he sucks at everything so thank you
just trying to chum the waters there but
yeah lucifer
even when it was on fox and then it went
to netflix it was also a very very easy
show to watch you know like even when it
was just a procedural and like no this
is fun i get 100 get behind this once a
week
and then when i got to be deeper and and
dig into some more themes and some more
like expanded narrative on netflix
um i i really i just enjoy it the
casting is great the production's really
good the writing's really smart
you know it's uh it is a fine fine
friday night which is about when my wife
and i usually like buckle down
for an episode of lucifer so i've been
doing that um
[Music]
i've also been doing some press ooh what
yes sir but when that
when it moved to netflix were they
allowed to start cursing and show nudity
um they probably were but they didn't
they kept it
the same show yeah i mean there might be
a uh
a [ __ ] here and there but there was
never any nudity you know and at this
point you can say
[ __ ] on nbc or fox anyway is that right
yeah goodbye everybody i'm off in fox
see you later i've been saying [ __ ]
professionally
who knew it went mainstream yeah i guess
you can't get away with that [ __ ] i have
seen that in like a network show
but i don't know that i ever watched
network shows in real time as much as i
watched them
later on so i assume maybe they bleeped
them out but i guess not
yeah no it's i feel like it was part of
the
fx fox cw like are we really in network
kinda do we really need the fcc rules
maybe not
hey man no argument here lower the bar
lower that's how guys like me
got in
um but yeah also been doing some press
this week
what have you done to impress for your
comic book my comic book right we we got
to announce
finally this book that i've been doing
with comixology for the last couple of
years called adora and the distance
a sort of graphic novel um about a
little girl's
fantasy quest journey from point a to
point b
that is also a book about autism and the
what what i imagine the inside of an
autistic brain
to be how it views its own
world and its life and its in its
reality and
been working on this book for on and off
for like 15 years
and finally was able to get a publisher
for it comixology
who came in and said do the book you
want to do do it exactly how you want to
do it
found an amazing artist named ariela
christine tina
from jakarta um and she killed it made
it look gorgeous
and comicsology is behind in a big way
so this was we got to announce
a release date which is june 15th just
in time for father's day
um and got to do a bunch of interviews
and previews and
and you know it's a smaller scale
production than let's say master's
universe revelation but
um you know even still
getting getting to talk about this thing
finally is uh is a joy
you don't have to raise one to lower the
other
there's just a scale difference more
importantly um
not in terms of veggie pure enjoyment
like i watch masters and
it like makes me cry i'm like i'm so
glad i did this and i bet you that book
of yours
does the same thing to you on a far
deeper level it does
you know and then to you know we started
getting blurbs back from people because
that's what
you know pr always say see if you can
get some people to read the book who
would maybe move the needle in the in
the marketplace
and so you know sent out some emails and
called in some favors and the first
person to give me a blurb for was neil
gaiman
and it's like well [ __ ] man this this
will help
thanks neil and then off mark
yeah um you know don't be calling people
gay mans
on the show that's not your place to
this neil person is not
you don't have to like uh out him
he's outed himself as a gay man before
everyone knows that neil is a gay man
indeed i'm proud you guys
welcome my friends to 90s theater
that was an old comic book world joke
indeed
wow you got a blurb from [ __ ] gaming
i got a blow from gaming
simone gave me one scott schneider gave
me one oscar nominee emily gordon gave
me one
uh damon lindelof wrote the introduction
to the book
i'm sorry am i am i pestering you with
names i i just i'm i'm
these names are going to crush me
they're dropping you just got a neo you
got a bullet time your way
around
um when does the book where more
importantly where can they pre-order the
book
um it's digital only for now
comixology.com it's a comixology
original
um it will follow later with a with a
print edition from darkhorse
um and yeah go to comixology pre-order
it it's out on june
15. so two weeks
two weeks um [ __ ] hey man look at
that [ __ ] way to accomplish too it
doesn't matter how long it [ __ ] took
you on and off
like you start a thing you finish the
thing you got a thing to show for all
that [ __ ] time
yeah and and getting to do it the way
you want to do it
about subject matter that you want to do
it about and stuff it's always wonderful
when you can find
people that'll back your play so thank
you to the good folks at comixology is
that like the comixology app comicsology
same guys the same guys and so they're
they're not just in the business of
aggregating
dc and marvel and image and whatever but
they make their own [ __ ]
they're making the fresh content yeah
look at this
[ __ ] we're learning something all the
time we learned about the [ __ ] ladies
charlotte pimpernell baroness emma whose
last name
yes and then thank you it finally
clicked and now we've learned that
comics ology is moving into the
publishing game
hell yeah um how did the how was the
reaction to your
peter parker uh spider band or whatever
burger spider bangs
um it was pretty good you know like the
reviews were pretty strong there
you know a couple people there's always
somebody who's not gonna dig it and
that's fine
um but by and large the reaction was
overwhelmingly positive
um you know asking for when are we going
to see more of this peter parker to
which i say
no idea and no plans but if they ask me
i will do more you know what's going to
happen is when we go back to the bar
finally hey banff man pop
in here when we go back to the bar
finally people are going to be throwing
that up
on the counter to get signed uh we just
uh referenced the bar when does that
happen
so uh we've had health department in
three times in the past week
um the first to check and make sure we
were adhering to covet protocols to
which i said
yeah we are but isn't this all up on
june 15th
she goes that's the rumor but we can't
say anything
because it's not our call so then they
came back to follow up
and then she came back to show off the
bar to one of her friends which was
funny because we all had a heart attack
and she was like she was like no i'm
just showing my friend the bar
um so i don't want to push anything
i think uh we look at doing it
whatever the tuesday is after the 15th
so maybe the 22nd
ish in there okay or maybe a saturday
afternoon
whatever that would be 26 or so
robert mills on uh chad is saying that
uh
newsome has just said it's being
extended
newsom said that the state of emergency
is being extended
but not the restrictions
on masks and dining and occupancy
so essentially newsom is keeping the
state of emergency so if something
happens
he can essentially send down orders
without having to go through legislator
legislature tony cole and chad is saying
what's going on with the audio
seems very muffled especially mark i'll
try to bring you closer
i think it's on mark i think mark's mic
might be a little over modulated
are you on it's i'm not automatically
adjusting volume
maybe turn it down slightly is this
better
yeah it's a little better okay i'm
trying to i'm
trying to make it better for you guys i
um
i do have some fun uh skim and villainy
news though
if we're sharing um scum and villainy
is now only the second
place in southern california selling
skywalker ranch wine so the
wine that is made from the grapes that
are grown
from skywalker ranch you can now get at
scum and villainy well
starting next week you can get it scum
and villainy so you can come in and
get skywalker ranch rose or chardonnay
or uh pinot noir very smart
very on brand how did that happen um
we have a new barn manager named carissa
who's just going after stuff
so she got that all hooked up
and uh see places the other one disney
the other one is disney
look at that [ __ ] man you rubbing elbows
with the big rat
yeah i'm always wondering how hard i can
poke um
but i felt like this is pretty simple
yeah you're you're safe i mean it's if
anything if there was like some sort of
corporate mustache [ __ ] villain
somewhere where this would be
well here's the here's the thing
george still owns the the vineyard
it's still his wine company and
uh i don't based on his comments
of the past few years i don't know if
there's any love lost
with disney so you know i
i think he'd have our back i'd like to
think he has our back
and he doesn't make movies anymore he
doesn't have lucasfilm or
ilm or any of this stuff anymore so like
he's making money off of his wine
right and we're buying the wine so we're
in business with mr lucas now
which is something that disney uh it
isn't anymore
yeah i do like that you're imagining
that george lucas
is like all right here's the four
billion dollars i got from selling this
stuff
and the two grand that i got from scum
and villainy and wine
thank goodness that this is showing up
he's a businessman he knows that every
[ __ ]
could you imagine when he started
bottling wine
he knew he had a base a customer base to
begin with
and he had no idea that one day there'd
be a bar
set in a spaceport
on the streets of hollywood in
california man that would become
his greatest fan and proprietor of his
wine i've seen all them [ __ ] grapes
man that where they grow them at
skywalker ranch
that's right outside the sound mixing
facility so there's like rows and rows
of [ __ ] grapes
and you walk through a fencing thing and
you get inside and that's where we mix
dogma that's where the stag theater is i
think yes
that's where i saw um
uh the phantom menace trailer for the
first time like before it
you know went out into the world and
[ __ ] so the i
i can vouch for those [ __ ] grapes man
they're all over the [ __ ] place over
there at skywalker
i'm not a wine person like i don't
like it but i had some of the chardonnay
you know it's it's tasty
it is good um we're seeing here in the
chat
uh omni432 says i like the idea in the
chat
of you guys meaning us having our own
brand of wine and calling it jeff's kiss
ooh jc why don't you
why don't you get some of that skywalker
[ __ ] throw it in a bottle with a
different label
we'll charge about 10 bucks call it
jeff's kiss uh what is kiss in french
bouche i think yeah i think
his mouth
all right well then let's let's find out
what kiss is he's been telling people
for years boosh me thinking you were
saying kiss me
and mouth me
um jeffrey lembrassee
the uh the uh jeff's jeers says
that's probably funny that's for the
malt liquor that we survived
that's when something that's when
something is beyond jeff's kiss when
it's so
insanely off the shot superlative it's
jeff's jizz
jessica ladies and gentlemen and for
[ __ ] that very rare occasion
jeff's cheers yeah um all right
the uh let's uh let's uh enough about
george lucas and his booze he needs no
help whatsoever the guy's already
[ __ ]
got enough of our money i remember when
i mixed up there at skywalker for the
first time i sat down in a chair
like this wooden rocking chair that you
know nicer than the more rustic i would
say than you would see it
you know a [ __ ] cracker barrel but
same
same idea and i said to myself i was
like with
all the money that my parents spent on
star wars toys
i probably own this chair i probably
don't care
that's about it did you secretly like
put a little metal plaque on him back
there's like
kevin smith i did know i went the jersey
way i pissed on it that's how you mark
the territory
yes from mark just farting the cushions
a few people have asked what are you
drinking i'm drinking uh mighty kind
makes uh movies uh cannabis seltzer this
is violet mango it's cbd
in it so it's got no sugar it's all
vegan and whatnot i love it
that answers that question a lot of
people are asking have they already
talked about sweet tooth
yes we i deep dove on sweet tooth
i uh i got a sweet tooth from being so
[ __ ] sweet to sweet tooth you can go
back and watch it
earlier in the show uh but we did our
upfront chit chat
uh except well we could talk about i
guess that's part of the news
and we got news from last weekend this
week we got we got a selection of both
so we better get to it because there's a
bunch to talk about
ladies and gentlemen mr mark bernardin
is an award-winning
news newsman i'm sure he's won did you
ever win an award uh i was at a magazine
that did win
magazine of the year um one of the
ellies
so i suppose i can technically glom on
to that totally counts man why not i'm
still living off the glory of clerks you
could totally get a little
ew shine absolutely the uh
the man is known for bringing you the
news that we need every week that we
here
discuss and you get to see us react to
it and you get to see me
get mad that batgirl is not going to be
a movie which turned into a real [ __ ]
story last week
and taught me taught me a lesson to keep
my opinions to myself i was like
this god damn it this should be a movie
and the internet every story was like
kevin smith uses foul language
he's so [ __ ] mad about batgirl being
a tv show
look i'll take batgirl any way i can get
her i just think you know what you know
what i already dug this grave
let's move on mark while i
i have a smooth crisp to enjoy the
smooth crisp taste of a cbd
only cigarette mark why don't you take
us into our first story of the evening
mark bernard with the news ladies and
gentlemen
bernardin means rose in french
no it doesn't matter i i
if i had to guess and it's purely based
on some very dodgy genealogical research
bernardin is an italian name that got
frankified
um by a sort of merchant who left
um florence i think and then went to
france bernardini
um then went to france dropped the eye
became bellend
um and i don't know if bernard means
anything
our names don't mean [ __ ] my people came
from newark down to the shore hey you
didn't drop a letter look at you with a
rich history man that goes into [ __ ]
europe and [ __ ]
it starts in [ __ ] italy and then
moves to france and then
well the name does
my people traveled from one place to
another as well it was less romantic
oh that's just terrible
you ain't gonna get that kind of satire
anywhere else social satire ladies and
gentlemen
take that saturday night live i just saw
that for the first time ever saturday
night live
finished number one in its category in
the ratings
the category of late night variety tv
shows
no the category of entertainment on
television that's not
sports so based on its ratings
all year long it and if i'm wrong
somebody will [ __ ] correct me but
like
they took an honor they've never taken
before and they're in their [ __ ] 40
some odd year 47th 46th year 436th
season
it feels to me and i don't know the
honor that they're speaking of
but it's a little bit how like every
radio station is number one in something
it's like we're the number one drive
time between you know two o'clock and
three o'clock in the morning here in
spokane washington
okay great i don't see how
saturn live gets more eyeballs than like
grey's anatomy um but if they're saying
it does
congrats lauren michaels and company
on an honor well one
um esco 430 says hey guys kevin on a
previous fat man podcast you had a dope
ass he-man hockey jersey
is that up for sale at the secret stash
um they will be
sooner or later uh because it's from the
good folks um there's one right here
behind me
it's a skeletor one uh
very jaunty oh i mean it's crazy great
they're they make them like these
these cats these geeky jerseys cats
all right let me give them a free plug
geeky jerseys man they make incredible
[ __ ]
hockey jerseys i stopped wearing hockey
jerseys like after the heart attack i'll
be honest with you
i had a heart attack in a hockey jersey
and then i was like after i survived it
i was like maybe i should
lay off hockey jerseys and i was you
know superstitious or whatever the [ __ ]
so
for a red hot minute which is about
three years i stopped wearing hockey
jerseys but these geeky jersey cats man
i mean look at this [ __ ]
this will make a man put a hockey jersey
on again
lords of destruction battle cat one so i
want to see if they'll do some [ __ ]
some jay and silent bob type stuff man
really
good but anyway go to geeky jerseys kids
they got i think they got that the
skeletor one was limited edition so i
don't think that's still around but the
battle cat one
definitely is still around um all right
back to you mark time to time to do the
news man sound
like one of those corrupt news
organizations that's all about sales and
[ __ ]
how are we considered serious newsmen if
we're so busy whoring hockey jerseys and
[ __ ] ball trimmers and
and [ __ ] cbd water that we may or may
not have a piece of
baseball can meanwhile
in kuwait
um all right what's going on um first
thing uh is a thing that i haven't
gotten to take part
pardon yet because i haven't been to the
parks in a in a dog's age
but avengers campus opened up in
disneyland
california adventure have you looked at
any of the videos online
the one that i saw i mean i saw a couple
i saw anthony mackie
handing the shield to the parks
version of captain america i saw
the crazy ass [ __ ] spider-man robot
that
flips through the air that's what i want
to talk about
yes that's that is nuts that because
when it flies through the air i've
watched all these videos on
twitter and you know i was like oh there
must be a [ __ ] rope or something that
i'm not seeing but my kid
went to avengers campus for like some
preview thing
um her and some of the kids from her
she's on that tv show cruel summer
summer's on free form reforms part of
the disney family
and my kid is a like disney nut dude
just like
lives like she's had season passes since
we moved out here so she
you know a lot of people like disney and
[ __ ] and if they wind up working for
disney they're like oh how neat i get to
go to disneyland
that's the reason like harley took the
job she was
in the disney family and i could go to
the parks for free and [ __ ] so
she's a huge huge fan so she got to go
to that avengers campus event that was
not the opening night event but the next
day it's
kind of closed off and [ __ ] so i asked
her you know
was well first off i tried to go the
moment i heard she was going i was just
like well
like uh and she was like well i'm
bringing austin or austin's her
boyfriend and i was like well
don't worry about [ __ ] you know me
i'll
i'll make a few calls i'll see you there
you know
at avengers game i know people we do fat
man beyond you don't think
on avengers campus and i couldn't i
couldn't get onto avengers campus mark
but to be fair they did like initially
they were like no this is a closed event
you can't come and i was like oh i
understand it was totally fine but then
they
called back they were very sweet they
were like look we found a way to
to bring you in if you're if you're
interested but it was on the day
it turns out that i was doing all my
masters in the universe stuff
so i had a chance i wanted to go then i
couldn't go then i was allowed to go but
i couldn't go and stuff but the reason i
couldn't go is good reason because i was
sitting around
talking about masters of the universe
which is like one of my favorite topics
so
long story short i didn't go the kid did
she saw
spider-man in real life no strings no
ropes she's like it looks like a human
[ __ ] being
is literally doing a spider-man over
your head
in the sky she's like it's just like you
see in the video it's incredible
it's a [ __ ] animatronic like lincoln
but
not connected to anything right so what
is it powered by batteries or [ __ ]
you know i i don't know the thing that
that and i don't want to know because
there's something wonderfully magic
about just
spider-man it is true magic like when i
watched it
like you hear people in the videos going
wow like
it captures your imagination i'm a 50
year old man i know all this shit's fake
but for one second
i was like holy [ __ ] they got a guide a
spider-man up there
not thinking like nobody could do that
like it's impossible to do
that pose to do that very comical pose
but it looks like the [ __ ] movie
hats off to these [ __ ] imaginings
i'm pretty sure he's going to come in
and tell us who worked on
this particular robot as one of his
final projects
it was one of grant imahara from
mythbusters final projects
that he worked on final he passed he
passed
last year last year that's right oh my
god
was working on that animatronic
yeah i mean it's a robot he was working
on
the balance and getting it to flip and
uh and i saw
gosh it must have been less
over a year and a half ago video of just
the
uh the robot like the weird robot
flipping through the air
that he was working on where it's it's
still it looked more like ultron than
spider-man
because it was just the steel frame but
it was it was crazy he was doing all the
calculations and stuff to make it work
um
it is it's i've seen a lot of [ __ ] but
that really took my breath away where i
was like oh my god they can still
you know [ __ ] surprise me with little
magic that looks funny
kid said the whole [ __ ] place is
wonderful she had like one of the best
days in her life
going to the park and then she went over
to the other park she she wrote rise of
the resistance as well which he was
saying was fantastic but the biggest
praise
that she had and she loved it all the
spider-man ride she says incredible she
came home with a little spider-bot and
[ __ ]
but this kid would not stop talking
about the pim kitchen
yeah she got the big pretzel they got
like a tiny bavarian pretzel goes behind
a conveyor belt into a pim
particle machine that comes out like the
size of your head
they had a vegan meatball you know she's
vegan and stuff
meatball and spaghetti made with
impossible meat and the meat she's the
meatball
was like big like this but the fork was
tiny
so they're being real clever with the
with the food in the kitchen i know some
people were like
they only got one ride the spiderman
ride but it's like well and it's not so
much a
a ride like woo but it's one of those
interactive ride games like the toy
story ride
right police shoot webs and [ __ ] like
that's cool it's kind of dope so they
but there's another ride coming and
stuff and they do have the
guardians of the galaxy ride is kind of
nearby but
she said it was absolutely fantastic so
i look forward i'm going to go before i
head to jersey
nice yeah not since spider-man turned
off the dark
have i seen a spider-man thing quite as
impressive as
flippy robot spider-man did you see
spider-man turn off the dark
i did were you there one of the nights
where the guy hit the ground
i know i was there one of the nights
where the guy was just suspended in the
air for like 45 minutes
you were there for one of those shows
yeah yeah i went to like a preview
um a preview performance where they were
still working out the kinks
so like the first two times when the
dude just swings across the theater
you're like oh that's [ __ ] rad well
done julie taymor
and then the third time he's just kind
of stuck up there
and then it's like being in space
mountain or whatever
when the ride stops and like the lights
come up and there's some text just like
working to free a dude from the harness
on the top of the ceiling because he's
stuck
huh you turned off you turned on the
dark
turned off the light that was dope i had
no idea you were [ __ ] there for the
not only there for that musical but
there for like [ __ ] when it fell
apart
how was the music you know it's
it was you two or the least it was like
you know bono and the edge
i don't think it was the whole band and
so like there's a couple of good songs
but all in all it was a a noble
experiment
in in theatricalizing spider-man
that ultimately didn't do any of the
things you wanted spider-man and or
theater to do
so way to spend billions of dollars
on a thing that didn't work it was mark
bernard for you ladies and gentlemen
yours your play
your your comic book thing could be dead
for years
he'll still find a way
to come out and kick its corpse and
remember to dust off my
theater critic hat and just blow you in
the broadside
that thing that's 20 years old
give him his last few months kids once
he makes splinter
that all goes away you guys that was
amazing you know what i know how hard it
is to make something now speaking of
which
uh somebody pointed out in our chat that
you they looked right before we went
uh you were up to 190 000 192
000. it's
bananas i want to go to your wrap party
sounds like you got a lot of money
oh yeah we're spending all of it on
[ __ ] in and out trucks
um
such a super waste of money considering
we just go to in and out but the good
news is we wouldn't have to wait in line
that's the only bad part about in-n-out
that's that's that's the beauty of the
trucks and i did i did make a promise
on the kickstarter campaign that if we
hit 200 000
then i will do a fat man beyond special
re-reviewing the snyder cut
in the most positive light possible wow
did somebody buy it
um i just said like hey if we hit that
money i will give that for free to
everybody
so like if this is the thing you want
we're now eight grand away
from me spending probably some of the
time you're back east
unable to do shows i will be back west
doing a solo all right gang let's it's
strapping let's find it kids that's
gotta be worth the money go to
kickstarter.com
look for splinter movie splinter film
uh splinter short glitch or short um
and uh throw a few more bucks into
mark's kitty
so that he has to chow down on some
[ __ ]
thick watches uncut
snyder [ __ ]
oh what happy times they'll be oh man we
live in a
we live in glorious days my friend we
live in a society
as the joker himself tells us yes
um yes true avengers campus ladies and
gentlemen is open
and uh it sounds like heaven on earth
man but it sounds like they're doing a
lot of fun [ __ ] look
i'd go to disney right now even if they
were like you know all that's open to
the bathrooms i'd be like great i
haven't seen it in so long
i'd be happy to [ __ ] go but uh it
sounds like now that they're up and
running
throwing avengers campus into the mix
holy [ __ ] i don't
have it in florida's or just los angeles
um i think they're building them
in various other parks but the
disneyland one is the first one to open
more of this man more of the star wars
park [ __ ]
marvel park what else can they do i mean
the star wars
cruise i think they're building a whole
[ __ ] cruise ship that's supposed to
be
insane immersive hotel experience where
like you don't leave it for three days
straight man oh
wait i'm gonna do that i am legit doing
that and they keep threatening and not
threatening but going like the price is
gonna be
six grand i'm like are you kidding me
like i'll
i guess what man my kid she don't need
her [ __ ] inheritance i need
in this let's start a kickstarter just
to [ __ ] go on that day
partner to wake up and be like what
happened to my 200 grand
in the middle of this snyder cut
commentary i'm gonna take that money i'm
gonna
get some of that um all right what other
news we got um
we had uh we had talked a couple of
weeks ago uh about the fact
that um we were going to check in with
jupiter's legacy
the new uh netflix superhero show
from the mind of mark miller but we
haven't gotten around miller he's got
uh he sold the miller world to netflix i
remember years ago and [ __ ] like that
yeah and this was the first part of uh
first ip that they made of all his stuff
indeed it is the first one to come off
the assembly line um
it was received relatively well in its
first week
um and then by let's see
this week it's fourth week um
has been effectively canceled on the
netflix's
they know it's done they know it's done
um you know it's according to netflix
they're not
done with the miller verse because they
did give a series order to supercrooks
which follows a group of villains
planning a heist and it's part of the
jupiter's legacy world
but those characters and those actors
are not coming back for a second season
and it sounds like that wasn't the
original plan to do super crux
next i don't believe it was um
and and juba's legacy was an expensive
gamble
they spent a reported 200 million
dollars on that first season
which is a lot how many episodes 200
no no eight i mean look i don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] because i make low
budget [ __ ] but that sounds pricey
it it it was a lot
um stuff though right lots of costumes
and
and uh costumes and and you know lots of
makeup and and
you know a decent amount of special
effects but
you know the witcher which also had all
of those things
plus set in a period fantasy world
didn't cost 200 million dollars
and the witcher is very popular correct
incredibly popular they're now
they i think they're in the middle of
production on season two they're doing a
prequel series
um but yeah so this this
is not good news for netflix
per se um because it's a big investment
that they hope to pay off in a bigger
way
um and i think probably what ended up
happening was
a decent amount of people showed up that
first week to watch it
and then didn't come back and then it
didn't pull in anybody else who hadn't
already sampled it that first
time um because then netflix is a
completely data-driven place
and without those numbers without that
audience they weren't willing to roll
the dice anymore
so um
well i feel bad for mark miller
but he's getting another tv show you
know i
it's hard to feel bad because he did
sell this to netflix for a gigantic sum
of money
super crooks you always want you know
[ __ ] everybody to
yeah move forward and stuff like that
he's you know
it's it's this is the first definitely
the first one out the gate
yeah so you would hope that there was a
yeah a win out the gate but hey you're
talking to the guy who made yoga hosers
kids
and mall rats which was much maligned
and totally box office failure in 1995
so
i know wherever i speak it it stings
when the thing that you think is like oh
man i can't wait till everyone sees it
and loves it as much as i do
that's what i'm dreading for masters of
the universe revelation i love this
thing so [ __ ] much that's why that
press day
was such a relief for me because like at
least i heard from other people that
were very very
enthusiastic positive about it as well
but like you know like
i you i love it so much and i'm not even
the sole creator i'm just one of many
hands on it and stuff
but you just want everyone to love it as
much as you and you know
when if it doesn't connect that it
doesn't matter if they gave you all the
money in the world that like just
hurts your heart and stuff but you know
you're not allowed to [ __ ] about it
because you're breathing rarefied air
that you get to do it at all
that's why it's like every once in a
while you stop i don't know if others do
but i stop in this business i'm
gobsmacked because i'm like
it is crazy that like sometimes you can
walk into a room and be like
there's it's about a little boy who's
like
you know a deer well i guess that like
is proven as a comic book and then
robert downey jr walks it in right but
like
it's weird that like like the wachowskis
went in and they were like the matrix
and that somebody got it and then he was
like all right
and [ __ ] just gave him a bunch of
money to go
realize this fantasy that they had and
and that's kind of the
the world of of you know the studio side
of the business or even on the lower end
of the pool with me because even if it's
not like
you know warner brothers or universal
paying your check you still have to pull
together
a series of investors if not invest
yourself
and so you're convincing people or
asking people to like give you money to
go [ __ ] make pretend
so when something doesn't like hit the
way you
wish it would and again i'm speaking
from experience
like you know it hurts but then you very
quickly learn as i did back in 1995
that you can't [ __ ] like
you want to talk about [ __ ] first
world problems like
i remember i remember whining a little
bit about mall rats doing poorly to my
father and my father was a realist mark
my father asked me how much did you get
paid to make that movie
and i told him and he was like okay do
you know how many years i had to work to
get close to that figure at the post
office
count your blessings kevin and you know
he's absolutely right so
yeah i feel bad for mark as creative i
feel bad for it was steve tonight was in
charge of this show
um he he was on the show for a stretch
and then parted ways with netflix
um and then another showrunner came in
to finish
um the first season he did such a great
job with the daredevil season one
yeah greatest seasons of tv i've ever
seen and stuff so you feel bad feel bad
for
netflix nobody you know everyone wants a
huge [ __ ] win but it doesn't sound
like
it sounds like they're is this count as
a pivot
it seems to be you know because they
they netflix invested in
mark miller and and this gallery of ip
and it's not a thing that they're just
going to leave at the side of the road
because
one thing didn't work once and so
supercrooks is happening
there's another animated series that
he's doing that's i think going to the
cannes film festival
the magic order is still in development
over there so yeah they're not letting
it
die um it's just all right this one
didn't work let's see what else we can
do
those that's uh that's breathing
rarefied air man if you can you know
walk from something that's
uh ending to right away to something
that's beginning
indeed um well at least they made it
right
at least we're still in the world where
everybody's like let's give it a shot
yeah you know i mean it's we do live in
this place where
they made a jupiter's legacy tv show
which
might not have happened 15 years ago on
our childhood
to say the least let alone 15 years ago
yep
um where next uh next um
in a move that surprises nobody um
cruella
is going to get a sequel um
was disney was it very successful um
it pretty much was i mean it got you
know really high on rotten tomatoes
um the it grossed almost 30 million
dollars in the box office
which you know even in a non-coveted
time would have been impressive
um but it also did incredibly well on
disney plus
which was uh one of their premier
releases so they got money that way as
well
they give numbers on the the disney plus
i'm putting the
the uh lawnmower back in the box if
people are like what are you doing
according to data from samba tv which
seems to be this
third party reporting on streaming
viewership
it was seen by almost 700 000 u.s
households
so that 700 000 people who all dropped
um 30 bucks to watch cruella at home
somebody do the math real quick
uh it's not going to be me
bamf math hey banff
math i look at he's literally doing it
on paper off-camera
where's your abacus
um sounds like a lot of money bam
hey look who's here 21 million
so they got how much of the box office
26.5 of the box office 21 million so
that's 47 million dollars this thing
made in its opening weekend
um which ain't too shabby and clearly
enough to
to at the very least start uh
development on a sequel
uh yeah she's a star people like her
quite a bit
they really do have you watched it
corellia not yet i wanted to over the
weekend but
you know got stacked up with lots of
other things i wanted sweet tooth i
wanted cruella i wanted to do more modok
um but uh but then again the weekend is
young
air of east town and ended last did you
watch it
i did wasn't it [ __ ] phenomenal oh so
good
so good so well done across the boards
uh
yeah just i was sad to see it end but at
the same time
happy to see them because i did not see
the end chapter coming
i did know that like you know when i
when things were wrapping up in the
first seven minutes i was like
this doesn't feel right yeah perhaps
this
this well goes deeper than we thought um
insanely well done and i loved
like the situations it's set up in terms
of who against who
and something like that yeah i mean it
was great very well made and she's just
[ __ ] wonderful i'll watch her do
anything but it was incredibly cast
mayor of east town definitely worthy
watch hacks continues to be
an incredible [ __ ] watch jean smart i
think
secretly owns hbo because she's on three
shows but it's really just goes to show
how [ __ ] good she is they could put
her on
every [ __ ] show like you know they're
making this sex in the city movie
without samantha put gene smart in that
role man
she could pull off samantha's mom uh it
is
it's she's so crazy good and in hacks
and the girl with her as well it's
really one it reminds me have you
watched it yet
not yet now it reminds me of ted lasso
in as much as wickedly funny where
you're like oh [ __ ]
but it has this gooey beating heart
at the same time so it's worth if you
lassoed me into ted
let me hack into your heart with hacks
mark
i appreciate an incredibly rock pun
well played all right where to next um
this is a little off pitch for us but
not that far
um creed 3 is uh is rolling uh
on its way towards production that ain't
off pitch for us the [ __ ] rocky verse
the creediverse
that counts like look if tarzan [ __ ]
counts
rocky could count it's another shirtless
white guy
[ __ ] why can't he be superhero as
well
um all right so uh michael b jordan is
directing
um creed three yeah and they've uh
they've announced that
jonathan magers who played atticus
in lovecraft country is enrolling as the
last the last uh man in san francisco
the last black man in san francisco
yeah yeah yeah but yeah we know him as
the guy from
uh from love lovecraft country yeah and
he was in
uh he'll be killing the conqueror and
ant-man and the wasp quantomania
he was in spike lee's defy bloods as
well
um but he's going to be the antagonist
they they haven't mentioned
who what character he's playing um
i i there's there's a piece of me that
knowing how these movies have gone
given who we've seen in each of them um
that there is a clubber lang connection
that could potentially be made
chat's blowing up with a lot of people
talking about
like it's clubber lag junior i've heard
[ __ ] tell that somewhere too how
would i have they haven't announced that
so why would that be in the air they
haven't
i mean it it feels like both a a logical
deduction to make
as well as a thing that you might want
it to steer away from which is
how many of the children of rocky's
previous foes will adonis creed be
fighting
he's gonna like at some point like
[ __ ] john cena shows up as the son of
thunder lips
i'll take it i'll do it that's what
makes it a rocky verse
like you need to bring back super
villains for the fights and [ __ ]
um i hope he is clubber lang junior man
oh my god cause
mr t is still [ __ ] up and around
correct mr t still up and around
um the same way in dolph lundgren
was in the last one
get t as your old anchor your you know
your classic
your legacy talent i hate to say the
word old but i'm old too and he's in way
better shape than me
i retracted because even though he's
older he could probably still kick my
ass
um apparently stallone is not coming
back for creed 3.
even more of a reason to get mr t yes
hey woman hey woman you done with him
come over here without you the real man
i'll bust you up that took me back to
like seeing it and i'm sitting next to
my father
my father like was just like yeah um
the uh all right the the wait mgm
owns rocky right indeed an mgm
has just been bought by uh
a little bookseller name of amazon
indeed a little
toilet papery called oh this means they
have the current michael jordan
jordan flick you know the tom clancy
movie and now they're about to have the
next michael b jordan flick which
michael b jordan is directing isn't he
indeed this will be his debut
um it's good business to be in the
michael jordan business does not seem to
be a shabby one
when i was at the mgm building years ago
for buckaroo banzai
i was in the lobby waiting to go up and
uh he came out he was doing creed press
for the first time
and i saw him in person and got a little
star struck because i was
he was on the wire
he's on parenthood i go deep cuts was he
on parenthood
yeah no no he was the tv
yeah and friday night lights
yeah he was on parenthood and friday
night
oh look at look at michael b jordan
fanboy banff boy jumping
i'm all about even revealing revealing
hidden [ __ ] depths here took more
unseen depths
i uh i made a lot of controversial
uh comments in 2015 when i said that
creed was my favorite movie of that year
everybody's like what about what about
episode seven i was like creed was my
favorite movie of that year
what a little [ __ ] pleasant polite
[ __ ] you are
um creed is a great [ __ ] movie and it
is on brand because it's the creative
verse i hope to god
hope to god well i hope there i hope
there is a god and sometimes right
i hope there isn't a god because if he
is a god
who has does not have a sense of humor
dogma has [ __ ] me forever
i hope there is a god mark because if
there is
it's going to be mr t's kid
i would like to see that that'd be dope
they can keep doing it man i want him to
see him fight rocky's kid
if we get [ __ ] milo ventimidia back
in here come on milo that's where it
should lead to eventually it's just like
you've got to fight rocky jr um
they don't have to fight i'll tell you
what we'll never have to fight
mark is for my [ __ ] cinematic dollar
because i like what they're doing with
the
with the cretaverse they're giving you
more of it my friend
take more take all my money jeff bezos
now that we know who owns mgm yeah
couldn't have couldn't have done that
before
there's a name roger kirkorian like that
was years ago
deep [ __ ] cut thank you they're
quirky and it's not enough
old [ __ ] hollywood items um all right
what's our next story
uh a little bit of casting news that uh
for the new
spider-man into the spider-verse sequel
issa rae
is joining the cast as jessica drew
aka spider-woman we're finally getting a
spider-woman
hell yes uh you may not be far you know
i wonder there's a chance we might get
her in uh
no no no she'll probably debut in
spider-verse and then she'll
they'll bring her into the spider-man
movies and [ __ ] like we won't see maybe
we see a [ __ ]
jessica drew in this metaverse story
that's coming our way
who knows but this is exciting to me
because graphically
i think spider woman is one of the most
beautiful comic book characters
ever created i had a pin board as a kid
um in my room of uh not spider-man
but spider-woman because i just not
because i was like boobies because i
thought
she was graphically it's a graphically
beautiful design and still remains so
uh to this day so i i can't wait to see
what they do with her
in the spider verse and i think issa rae
is really funny so that's a good choice
yeah no that's a very good choice um
let's see moving on the thing that i
never believed in my heart of hearts was
going to happen
seems to actually be happening which is
indiana jones
5 is starting production this week
when the movie comes out as i've read on
the internet
in harrison ford i was going to call him
harrison jones indiana ford
harrison ford will be 80 years old
yep i'm no aegis i'll watch him
[ __ ] i'll watch him mumble through
another 50 movie i'm
there for it man i'm happy to see my
childhood come to life
once again flea bags in it herself right
yes she is phoebe waller bridge mads
mickelson boyd holbrook
um shawnette renee wilson and thomas
kretschman
are all part of the supporting cast he's
gonna be turning the camera from time to
time and being like
he's really old but
um yeah i'm all for it man i'm glad i'm
glad he's getting another one in i'm
glad he gets another bite at the apple
because
you know no he don't deserve the crystal
skulls the last time he touched that
character
no and i'm telling you who's directing
it our boy james uh what's his name
james mangold who did logan he ain't
gonna drop that ball this is gonna be
one of the greatest indiana jones movies
ever made i guarantee it man he's got
too much to lose
you watch you watch how good this
movie's gonna be i mean i like the idea
that it's
that it's the guy who made logan which
is probably the best
last chapter of a long-running saga
movie that there's been
that's a great take [ __ ] that great take
man if you talk
if you walk away from this [ __ ] show
this week with two things
one a lady created the [ __ ] dual
identity
of superheroes and her name was baroness
emma
or z thank you learn it
know it live in it starting your history
scarlett pimpernell go check it out and
number two
what mark just said it was a minute ago
it's already forgotten
um somebody in chat imax said i liked
crystal skull y'all
um you know what good absolutely for me
i
it was not i look forward to what james
mangold's gonna do like and i think what
mark said is absolutely right that's
bizarre that's the thing the other thing
that we want
to show like mark said um the guy
who made logan is making what could be
the last indiana jones movie with at
least
our indiana jones yeah come on
you saw how good logan was i mean i just
i just look forward
to the final scene with the chubby black
kid
holding an indiana jones doll as they
bury him in the woods
before the scene where the girl stabs
[ __ ] in the eyes
he will liberate fleabag just stabbing
[ __ ] in the eyes
that's what they hired her to do like
she's like the little girl in logan
grown up right she's like him in the eye
that turns
the camera and she's like stabbing's
hard work
and boyd holbrook is still there with
the robot arm like i just
same [ __ ] uniform outfit from logan
where is it being set did they say late
six they haven't said
the the working theory as far as the
internet goes
is that it's might have like a 60 space
race theme
i'm seeing a lot in chat well maybe not
a lot but
truer ie says mangled killed logan
i don't feel that well i mean yeah yes
he did
but that was meant to be the last
story yeah like it was that was the
intent going into the project so it
wasn't like he arbitrarily killed him
it's like well that's what we all came
to see the last logan story
yeah um humongous feat
otto matan says i thought logan was way
overrated i thought it was boring
man this is the kind of moment that just
blows my mind on the internet i always
thought we were all in agreement that
logan was a fantastic movie am i [ __ ]
wrong
what world did i wake up in what [ __ ]
what do they call
what what a simulation is this
what timeline are we living in when
that's not the truth it's a [ __ ]
great
movie god i hear [ __ ] like that i'm like
why do i even try if the guy who made
logan is catching [ __ ] and i know for a
fact that's a great flick
then why do i even bother [ __ ]
makes no sense um all right what else we
got um
uh this this broke pretty close to like
two weeks ago so it's the oldest of the
old news
is that uh we timmy chalamet is going to
be playing
willy wonka in the new prequel
to the charlie and the chopper factory
um so they're doing another these movies
they are and this is about him being a
kid
um or the very least before he becomes
the
titanic candy magnate that he is when we
meet him
in uh willy wonka in the chocolate
factory and or charlie in the chocolate
factory who's directing do we know
a guy named paul king who's directing
from the screenplay he wrote with simon
farnaby
um the the only reason why i hold any
hope for this is because um these are
also the people who made the paddington
movies
oh there you go so there's this there's
no wonder timothy chalamet signed up
yeah um but so they're like that script
must be amazing to get that kid's like
hotter than hell
and he's part of that like nothing so
him signing on to this was like
either he's cashing in already or that
script must be amazing if it's the
paddington guys
or gals or whatever the paddington team
sounds like that that was the big lure
and it must
be a great script people love them
paddington movies
oh so good so like the second movie
is so surprisingly good them people
being marked right there i am one of
them it was it was on my top 10 list
whatever year it came out
um and apparently this is also a musical
so timmy chalamet is going to get to do
a little singing and dancing
he was good when he was on snl when he
also i mean he's always a good actor but
like he was
funny on snl as well yeah i i
never my soul cinematic exposure to him
is in things that call me by your name
um and so it's i i don't
light on his feet is not quite a thing
that i always think of when i think of
timothy chalamets but getting to see him
kind of be funny and be
lighter and be um be a a rogue
on screen in snl was was liberating
i can't get my correct head bob going
anyway um did you drink it away we've
seen him in the dune trailer though he
looks pretty awesome in that
i can't wait for doom when is that
october
i believe you [ __ ] mate we got to wait
the whole [ __ ] summer to get to dune
okay wait don't forget somebody get to
do it oh we get suicide squad though in
august
yes all right [ __ ] in
i just needed like a rest area before we
got to dune
it's all over connect because the next
rest stop ain't till october
i know um they also got black uh black
widow coming in uh
july yeah all right so we got some [ __ ]
to do this summer
i might be preoccupied wink wink you
might be off doing a thing
but and it's like july 9th is almost a
month away
yeah and i june already i know not
prepared for that
um there are some comic book things both
happening and not happening
on um on the cw uh ava duvernay's
naomi series based on a comic book by uh
let's see by brian michael bendis and
david walker
and so uh that that they did a pilot for
that show
ava due to vernet directed or wrote or
produced um
she let me see it's written yeah she
wrote it she co-wrote it and then
directed the pilot
um that got a pick up that got a pick up
um something else gotta pick up too
um let's see crazy
a couple of things uh black lightning
did not get a pickup
um and neither did powerpuff girls
uh which has been sort of kicked back
into quote-unquote development
yeah that was a big story last week yeah
when the script leaked onto the internet
uh and uh and then i think people got a
chance to look at
the reasons why it did not get a series
order
um was that a real script or did we not
do we know if that was real or if it was
just somebody
all reports are pointing to that it
having been a real script
um not potentially the shooting script
but at the very least a script that had
been
part of the process you know because i
think there had been some actors who had
read for it
said those were the lines
i feel like look you know i'm i'm
i didn't see it at the finished product
and whatnot i don't know the tone they
were going for
other than the few pages i too read on
twitter but it just felt
you know and this is coming from mr
[ __ ]
you know poopy mouth
[ __ ] weenie boy whatever the [ __ ] 37
dicks
[ __ ] stink pom all that bullsh jay
and silent bob himself
it just seemed like it like was not a
concept you needed to
really add sex to
even if they were grown up and the pages
that i read were
very and again i'm not condemning
but but this is me saying it me who's
written some [ __ ] really
profane dialogue over the course of his
career
it just seemed like you're gonna
you're gonna make bubbles say that
you're gonna make
awesome say that like and also just the
whole concept of like
them being broken you know
actor kids grown up and so they're kind
of dysfunctional
again from what i've read i'm not i
didn't see anything it's just what i
read online
was not the show that i was
hoping to see i you know i look i wasn't
hoping to see any live-action powerpuff
girl
thing it caught me by surprise like
everybody else but
i don't think it can't be done i just
you know
what if i with what i read is what they
were doing
like i seems like cw might have
you know made the right call and saying
like hey we want to try again sometimes
these things work that's why we do
pilots or something
mm-hmm yeah you can make that concept
work just it don't have to
you know just you don't like
you know again i sound like such a
hypocrite and it's not because i'm 50
kids like
i you know i i'm i'm gonna make a movie
hopefully very soon that's just
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] jokes but
you know i ain't the powerpuff girls and
i never was
and i never should be but i think that
like
to your point it's
when when you're trying to update or
adapt or modernize or sequalize or
whatever the thing is
you know you have to be candid and fair
with what the thing is to begin with
and like masters of the universe
could not sustain being a
vulgar thon potty mouth experience you
know
to cater to a 40 year old audience who
played with the toys when they were kids
because that's not what he-man is you
know you can update it you can modernize
you can give it you can enrich it
you can make the the themes and the
emotional stuff
a lot more vibrant but it's still got to
be what it is
and i think the problem is is that
powerpuff girls
forgot what it was and so yeah you can
update those those women you can talk
about you know superheroes who are now
you know grown up in their own
perspectives on having been child
superheroes
but it's got to feel more like josie and
the pussycats
the movie compared to the cartoon than
some drastic veering off of that spine
of what it meant
to be powerpuff girls like anything's
possible
but the the spirit needs to remain
intact otherwise
why are we doing it um
let's talk about um
do you have it in your news stories
about spider-man
um i have no more spider-man content
okay so one of the big rumors going
around this was probably from last week
was that uh you know spoilers if you're
not
if you haven't heard this [ __ ] but the
uh green goblin
is the head of the sinister six in
spider-man no way home and that green
goblin is being portrayed by none other
than
willem dafoe have you seen that
i hadn't seen it that's cool though
reported in a bunch of places
um so much so that you know it seemed
it's there have been a bunch of things
that have been reported in a bunch of
places that have slowly gotten
confirms or close confirms i hope that's
the case man
like that would be dope if they pulled
together a sinister six from across the
[ __ ] metaverse
and fought spider-man like
i mean we know that that um jamie foxx's
back is electro
you know i i'm not sure but i think
michael keaton is also back as the
vulture
perhaps um if he's not off busy being
batman we know we know doc ock is back
alfred molina's back as doc he confirmed
metaverse and stuff like that
so you know if you got the greatest hits
of all the spider-mans
um then that would be badass
i'm here for it um i hope that is the
idea bam you know
f-man is in hopefully with some deets do
you get
j jonah jameson versus j jonah jameson
as the same actor facing off against
each other
screaming at each other that is that's
worth a day of shooting for
like a five to ten second shot
you my friend i hope you get hired by a
better kevin
kevin feige that
is a marvel s idea that's fantastic
they better do that i'm gonna be
disappointed if there ain't some jay
jonah jameson
on j jonah james in action jj
jv jj oh man that's what we all come to
see
um uh how about the
uh you got the batman logo to talk about
we got the batman logo to talk about
director of stamp
man put that sweet picture oh my god
dude call me an easy mark but when i saw
the batman returns iteration of his
[ __ ] logo we know it's batman returns
because it's missing little feet at the
bottom of the tip as he wore in batman
the first movie so this is the batman
returns that
insignia indicating that
you know that's the last bat symbol we
saw him wear
and he's been wearing it for this long
and in a very
uh watchmen-esque uh
reference we see some bat i don't know
if
they intended it to be watchmen because
it doesn't form anything but
we see some blood splashed across the
bat insignia
incredibly powerful image for them to
put out there this is andy muschetti i
think i interviewed him
either at sundance or at the san diego
comic con i think
san diego comic-con maybe i forget no no
no yeah
he did uh one of the hit movies movies
yeah
i think i did um that that's
he's doing it right man he keeps putting
out like cool images just enough
that really like get people talking i am
super [ __ ] excited about the return
of michael keaton i saw some people on
twitter being like
you know we could have had this batman
showing the thomas wayne batman from
from uh from the original series what's
it called again um flashpoint
um he's like instead we're getting this
guy but i'm
i love this like this is how we get to
batman beyond man so i'm way down with
him
down like a clown so yeah that was a
[ __ ] fun ass
little tease right there what is that
blood mark whose blood is it robin's
blood
alfred's blood uh uh [ __ ]
vicky vale's blood
uh the harvey dense blood yeah
[ __ ] man like you imagine if we also got
billy d williams to come back as harvey
dent
and finally you get you get tommy lee
jones
and billy d williams and aaron eckhart
you get all the [ __ ] two-face you get
six-face six-space
thanks amazing for the price
um all right where are we going next um
when i said that i had no more
spider-man content i lied
um because aaron taylor johnson
is is going to be playing craven the
hunter
yeah man a quicksilver is going to
become craven
um what uh
i didn't see that coming nobody saw i
guess quicksilver is not coming back
anytime soon
apparently not or at least not this
version of it yeah it might create a
little brand confusion
um but he's a big dude of course he
could play crab he could do accents and
stuff
he's already got the accent with
quicksilver he coming
like so he won't be that far from raven
uh i was only surprised that craven's
getting his own entire
movie yeah i mean it seems as if sony
even even after their first go-round at
the sinister six fell apart
that they are still going to to plumb
the uh
the the barrel of spider-man characters
that they have
to make some [ __ ] um we're still getting
morbius we're getting carnage
you know through venom two now we're
going to get a
uh crave in the hunter movie and
there's also nothing saying that any of
these characters couldn't show up
in a marvel movie because sony and
marvel absolutely have
their their partnership about spider-man
so if you needed a sinister six you also
can add
venom and craven to it if you wanted to
uh robert h a banff man robert h
on uh chad is saying what's with the
last bit of the show
only being the logo and not showing them
talking
third week in a row but nobody else is
bitching
uh i don't know what he's talking about
yeah everyone no no he's the only person
saying that he can't see us so
we're all here yeah we're here i see you
do you see us uh looking at my streaming
machine
i mean i'm watching us on youtube while
we do this so
and on twitch so i think we're good
and here come all that we see you it's
fine thank you
um all right last story
um you up for it look the craven story
i'm waiting for is craven's last hunt
one of the greatest comic book stories
ever written um i believe it's jm
damatus is it mike zech artwork
maybe i'm wrong yeah we get to get there
then it becomes worth it
yeah [ __ ] that's one of the greatest
[ __ ] comic book stories ever told
from my money
indeed my money and i borrowed and bit
off of it for my daredevil run
that i did uh oh two more new years ago
over 20 years ago
i guess i'm coming up on 22 23 years ago
that i did daredevil
wow old mark getting old but keeping it
young with silly hats
silly hats and shirts speaking of which
jc put up those
shirts for pride month that we're
they're selling at the chivalry.com
um
i don't know if i sent you a graphic
that's the website
um but it's it's uh
yeah just click on it there you go
that's me and jay as the
and not so ambiguously gay duo i duo
um and look at this click on that
[ __ ] fourth of july shirt that's the
third one over
that's a great shirt um this is such a i
love these chai people
because they're like how about this and
i was like [ __ ] yeah do it
i totally wear that goddamn shirt it's a
[ __ ] fourth of design
fourth of july design that has me and
jay on a
on a dinosaur with the american flag
over us
[Music]
um the a lot of great shirts right there
at thechivery.com ladies and gentlemen
over to you mark sorry to
it's all right our last news story of
the week um
is a is a it's a sweet little one
howard university um is naming its
college of fine arts
after one of its more notable and famous
alums chadwick boseman
who attended the college before going on
to becoming the a-list actor
who would then play to charlotte
thurgood marshall jackie robinson and
james brown
um what so what is the it's the school
of entertainment or
it will be the chadwick a boseman
college of fine arts
um yeah and so the disney folks bob iger
they're going to lead a whole round of
fundraising
for an endowment to name you know new
buildings to be the home
and and for to end down new scholarships
and and all that stuff
felicia rashad is the uh is the dean
of the newly re-established college of
fine arts
um who i think was instrumental in
getting
um and getting them chadwick money to go
study
in the uk um namely
she convinced denzel washington to pay
at chadwick's way to go to to go to
theater school
i remember that story here in that story
yeah
so you know it it it remains sad
that chadwick had left us so so young
but
the fact that his alma mater is going to
carry his name on to keep inspiring
youth
um to chase their artistic dreams is a
it's a sweet little coda to that story
uh
short unfortunately short life but long
lasting impact mark
indeed uh show
that uh that concludes uh the news if
anybody out there in chat think we
missed a news story let us know
i've already seen some people ask about
the eternals trailer i guess we didn't
talk about that
um what a beautiful [ __ ] trailer boy
did they
visually raise the bar for uh
for what these movies can look like um
uh i still not sure what's going on
but i'm in i'm there uh you know
i too like everybody else i'm like well
if they're so [ __ ] powerful where the
[ __ ] were they when they know
i feel like that'll be part of the movie
i can't imagine they just [ __ ] you
know yadda yadda past that i'm sure
that has to do with the plot and i'm
sure we'll see that in the next trailer
or something but everyone looks cool and
and uh you know it's it's just i'm going
into uncharted territory for me because
i was never an eternals guy
yes you know unlike almost everything
else they've ever done if not everything
they've done in the marvel cinematic
universe
i'm going in like my mom would go in
you know somebody's gonna have to sit
next to me and do what i normally do
when i watch marvel movies with people
and be like well what you have to
do but i look forward to it i mean [ __ ]
man more marvel
uh less of everything else anyway but
it's goddamn beautiful looking
yeah i mean it's the when i when i
watched that trailer i thought back to
the other first trailers for marvel
movies that i was a little iffy about
specifically guardians of the galaxy
like i i had when i
went on the record saying i'm not sure
that this was the right choice
because what the hell is this who are
these characters what's this going to be
me too i was just like this is why would
you pick the bottom of the barrel ip
you've got so many characters choose
from guardians the galaxy's one of the
worst comic books i ever read
and it turned into one of the greatest
films i ever made yeah and then but you
look at that first trailer
it did an incredible job of convincing
you why you were going to watch this
movie
because it sold the tone of it and the
tone of it was fun
the tone of it was interstellar the tone
of it was candy-colored kind of jack
kirby
cosmic adventure and
the eternal trailer is gorgeous
and it evokes like sweep and epic
but i don't know what the movie is i
don't know what i'm supposed to feel
about it
and so that's what i was hoping for and
trailer number two i'm sure will tell us
a little bit more about what it's about
but
yeah daniel k has pointed out rightly
that i kept misusing the term this
evening saying metaverse instead of
multiverse my bad kids
my head is in crypto world sorry
dating bob's crypto studio um so uh yeah
multiverse my bad i didn't meant to say
that um just hitting on
let's see uh some you know rapid fire in
the chat from people saying the things
we missed
loki starts this week let's not forget
what day
the 9th wednesday the 9th so wednesday
is going to be
loki which means when we resume on
saturday when we come back together
guess what me and mark are going to be
likely blowing because [ __ ] this show
looks amazing
hell yes moki and on a wednesday no less
something to [ __ ] do in the middle of
the week
wait till the goddamn weekend for
everything good so yes
loki is coming soon and buy off all the
trailers i've seen
i'm [ __ ] in man it looks fantastic um
that came from uh lu nachwell
then there's as sin
[Music]
as sin city magic says the green knight
looks cool with a brown main actor in
the knights of the round table story
shut up and take my money have you seen
the trailer for the [ __ ] green knight
it looks so amazing it looks like
excalibur 2
yes that's what i thought when i saw it
i was like holy [ __ ] this reminds me of
like
the unsettling creep factor of
[ __ ] of of excalibur and but they
never did the
the green knights story did they no i
mean they
they they i mean it was about arthur and
eventually he would get knights on their
quest today
i think they sent gawain he was at one
point he was the guy that hung and then
the [ __ ] other knights boot [ __ ]
cuts him loose that morgana and her side
to arthur but i don't think they touch
on the green knight
in bournemouth's excalibur what a great
looking [ __ ] trailer
yeah dev patel who's the lead like he
just he looks like he's leaning into it
yes and and as they pointed out in the
in the
as sin city magic pointed out a brown
main actor
in a night of the round table story so
you know there's that as well but
but uh never mind how diverse it is
it's visually stunning yeah it looks
sumptuous it's one of those movies that
makes you go like i quit
like myself a director like this
um let's see what else people are
talking about
um
[Music]
i think that's it we hit them all
christine richie in the matrix anybody
hear about that yeah it just
broke i want to say like today
that uh they revealed that she was part
of the matrix company
no idea what she's playing the new
matrix yeah matrix four
uh she's really good man it's a wonder
she doesn't work more
remember she like worked forever when we
were younger and stuff yeah she's in
everything
yeah um i just watched her on something
recently
i rented some movie and she was in and
she was really good
i'm glad i'm glad to hear she's in the
[ __ ] matrix man
um let's see anybody else in chat before
we wrap
up the news the batman 2022 have you
heard that
uh the batman might be moving
um i hadn't heard that but
there are rumors there are wars and
rumors of wars mark
there are rumors that uh it may push
uh a little bit um somebody says do you
produce
jupiter's legacy got cancelled we
already talked about that
um
let's see i guess there's not
any news on celebrity family feud
or asks uh i don't know when does that
error they'll tell us but i don't
recently they sent me pictures like with
within them last month
the city still so it must be coming soon
yeah i get the feeling that it's
like mid to late june because i did see
their twitter feed
had uh had updated like an early teaser
about it but they didn't give any dates
uh cyborg rex is debunking uh the batman
rumors he says the batman rumors are
lies so there you go we've wasted your
[ __ ] time on that
uh magic chain smoker says there are
she-hulk set photos i haven't seen any
of those but [ __ ] i'd that'd be amazing
uh let me see um
we did issa ray in spider-man i mean we
already spoke about
issa rae and spider-man uh should sam
teaser did you see that um it was less a
teaser and more like
shadowy shots of zach levi in the
costume
costume looks better yeah
you know i like shazam it's a lovely
little movie so i look forward to this
but this movie ain't coming out until
2022 right that's what i saw
yeah yeah yeah so i mean yeah of of the
costume
oriented news of the week it seemed like
the batman logo
was the more evocative
indeed jonathan rosalia says wwdc is
tomorrow
that's uh the uh that's
apple thing right yeah the developers
conference where they will reveal
some other way to get money from my
pocket for a thing that i probably don't
need
but i will buy anyway they can have it
all i ain't saying this to get [ __ ] for
free because i'll tell you kids they
don't give you [ __ ] for free
not the [ __ ] you want you get a lot of
great [ __ ] don't get me wrong but if
you're like hey man can i get a computer
they're like you're out of your mind you
pay for that
i do i like i actually if i was a stock
buyer i'd buy apple stock because i do
buy apple products i love my phone i
love my laptop and i
spend a lot of time with them i spend
more time with my phone and laptop both
made my apple
then i spend with my wife made by gail
stanley
my mother it's important
to like the [ __ ] technology you spend
time with and [ __ ] like that this is not
an apple ad this is just a long way of
saying like
i'll buy whatever they're making but i
ain't gonna [ __ ] sit through a
conference no way
yeah i'll wait until the back end of it
where somebody says here's where they
decided to release
here's how they're gonna make the chords
you already have obsolete so you gotta
buy a whole [ __ ] ton of new cords
and here's how they're gonna get two
grand out of your pocket for a thing
that probably costs 75 cents to make
but i will give it to them anyway take
my money
um scorp scorpius says that jensen
ackles is getting ripped
for his role in the boys coming up
uh wesley kellison says a new master and
commander is in the works
i saw that yes prequel is that what it
is
yeah or at the very least you know
there's there's a good
dozen mastering commander books i
believe
is there any of them got a giant shark
that terrorizes the boat for the whole
movie and
i don't believe so but uh call me when
they do
[Music]
um no but i know a lot of people like
that so good for them uh henry cavill
and highlander
i mean i don't think that's news is it
we talked about it on our last show
meaning what he's been re-upped or
something uh well he was cast
as the lead in highlander oh highlander
i was
confusing it with witcher i'm sorry i
was enjoying those cbd smokes perhaps a
little bit
um that's right he's the highlander now
here we
are we're the princes of the universe
um all right so i guess we've uh we did
it
oh people are getting political in the
[ __ ] chat room mark they're saying
right to repair andrew mora says right
to repair
over apple yeah but what if you what if
you can't repair what if you're one of
those idiots that
like honey how do i get
you know we're not all andrew mora man
some of us need umura some of us need to
[ __ ] worship at the altar of apple i
am fine with a closed system that i have
no access to
exactly all right you get off that tim
apple's dick he's a smart guy
damn fan what's up i just i'll point
this out real quick but k
flag says uh it might be an apple ball
shaver
they're gonna go after some of that oh
man
where's our where's our loyalty go in
that instance
to manscaped or to apple because we just
we just blew them for 10 minutes
um i'll say you want to show off those
he-man toys
are you able to i don't here i'll show
you at least one
there was one i saw on instagram this is
the one or
this is the one i put up on uh
on twitter this week man i put it up
because i on that press day
um this is the same guy who did the box
art
gorgeous box art and it's box art based
on our art from the show
is the same fella who did our jane salam
bob reboot figures
um there's the heads of the other
characters right there
these are going to be on shelves kids
when the show drops
uh july 23rd so these will probably be
on shelves
late june early uh july and it's a
master verse line 30 points
of [ __ ] articulation 30. you know
what i had on my star wars figures
five at best question
firecracker six does adam have like a
yellow belt
above his uh loincloth he does it's it's
kind of uh
yeah it's definitely there okay because
you can't really see from far away i'm
like that is a low-rise [ __ ]
oh well well done on brand landscape
ladies and gentlemen
i will say we talked about how to get
rid of
unwanted hair what if you want to bring
your hair back
who's our second sponsor if you want to
keep the hair you want to keep the hair
you have
there you go there you go what a what a
great tease this is a guy
who wants to keep all the hair he can
look at him our iteration of skeletor
ladies and gentlemen
indeed mark hamill skeletor right there
the lord of destruction
um he's got himself a hit the havoc
staff inside he's got shaping staff
i got more toys but that's the only two
other shows i'm not sure if i'm supposed
to show them but regardless
we're all right here talking about the
fact that like sometimes
a man a woman we want to hold on to our
hair
sometimes we're not as gifted as a lot
of you out there with lion's manes for
heads of hair and stuff like that
we can't all be as blessed as you and
those who
of us who are not as blessed as you we
just pray every day oh sweet
uh heaven of hair how how can we
keep our hair and one day our prayer was
answered ladies and gentlemen
and our prayers was answered by keeps
follow along at keeps.com kids if you're
ready to take action to prevent hair
loss go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com fat man
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man to get
your first month
free k-e-e-p-s dot com keeps.com
man keeps is a second sponsor of the
night kids
and they've been with us for a red hot
minute now
feels like definitely through the entire
quarantine and stuff so i feel like
i feel like we've helped a lot of people
keep their hair
at the first half of the show as jc
pointed out
our good friends at manscaped help
people lose their ball hair
but the second half of the show
sponsored by the good folks at keeps.com
these folks are going to help you keep
the hair that you want
right up there isn't that right mark
indeed and they offer a simple stress
free way to do it
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months
low cost they're just ten dollars a
month and keeps offers generic versions
of the
of their drugs they're only two fda
approved medications that can prevent
hair loss
keeps offers them both and prevention is
key
treatments can take up to four to six
months to see results so act fast
thankfully we at least give you an
easier way to begin that journey
if you go to keeps.com fat man to get
that first month
for free don't feel alone man if you're
sitting there going like oh i'm going
through something nobody
understand i gotta wear a backwards
baseball caps even goofy funny ones to
distract from the fact that i'm
not keeping my hair just remember you're
not alone two out of three men will
experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are
35 men so get your get your sex in
before then kids because once you lose
it
nobody nobody wants to keep you you're
what i'm saying
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness i know
one or two of them not going to say
their names
uh there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both what are you waiting
for man if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss
and you want to help out the show that
you watch every week
this show right here fat man beyond you
go over
uh to keeps calm k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to receive your
first month of treatment
for free free what do you
go that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to get your first
month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com keeps.com
fat man we thank the good folks at keeps
man
for continuing to to find
you know [ __ ] value in this
janky ass show as they would say
back east this is a janky ass show
um that's not cultural appropriation is
it uh jackie i don't believe so
gotta be careful gotta be careful out
here over in uh
in east town when they're getting their
rolling rocks on
having some water water going to the
wawa
yes town um
all right um there it is kids
uh we've done the news give it up for
the man
with the nose for the news the way that
tabitha
had a nose for magic tabitha
their last name i don't know i thought
you were going tabitha soarin
on mtv news like that's a that's a deep
cut
this is a deep cut no tabitha you know
[ __ ] uh
uh you know darren you witched what was
their last name
uh no no darren was her dad
what was the mom's name samantha sam
did they have a last name they must have
it would be his last name right because
that was the of
they had a traditional tabitha stevens
thank you there you go
stevens man uh gary smith hit that one
well well he hit it too but the first
one who hit stevens was
nowhere bound well done there's somebody
who wasted a lot of time like us
watching [ __ ] old tv shows
indeed um all right man now that we're
done with the news and we're on hour 18
of our [ __ ]
show and you bought some manscaped
you went to keeps.com hopefully you went
to the chavery.com and bought some
shirts
you've gone and bought some movies from
be
kind we've sold you every mark sell them
your shirt quick
the one off my back no man the other one
that you sell
all the time yeah embattledclothing.com
uh get yourself a resistances fertile
shirt or uh
be humble let [ __ ] know uh use
the code mark 15 at checkout save 15
off your order uh tr morris you know we
do the show in real time and so when you
look at chat you
kind of you're at the mercy of of
whether this is a rumor or not but
have you heard this rumor that wwe might
be bought by disney or universal
um i did hear a i guess
a little something about it i don't
i don't follow the wwe so i don't it
didn't mean much to me when i
encountered it
interesting um don't forget mark
uh in a world where we're selling
sending people places to
spend money and whatnot donate to mark
short the splinter
short go to kickstarter and hit uh
search splinter short
you throw a few more bucks in the coffer
man few more
alms to the poor and guess what mark's
going to [ __ ] just give a slathering
[ __ ]
indeed to the snyder cut snyder uncut
all over his face neck and chest
jeff jizz will be happening
that's worth the money right there kids
don't forget kickstarter.com
uh splinter short all right banff man
get in here and do what you need to do
bamf uh we need critical thinking says
it looks like kev's
wearing sweet tooth merch let me tell
you something if i could
i would if you're just tuning in you
miss me blowing [ __ ] sweet tooth
which sounds way dirty that meant to
considering the lead of the show as a
child so i'm talking about the show
not the character um what a great show
this is on netflix
go [ __ ] watch it i'd proudly wear
some [ __ ]
sweet tooth gear you hear me netflix i
would totally wear a sweet tooth [ __ ]
headpiece and [ __ ] particularly if it
covered up the fact that
i did not get to keep some time
keep it on brand keeps.com ladies and
gentlemen don't lose hope like i did
um all right banff man what do we got
your job is to
find us questions we uh asked jc to come
in and pick
three questions for us this is the hot
part of the show where jc is at his
absolute
most powerful this is when he has raises
the sword power
and he has the power because he has the
power to fulfill your dreams by
passing your forward your question
forward or
ruin your night by [ __ ] giving the
wrong question
let's see what happens as we turn the
show over to
scum and villainy's very own jc
riefenberg
where did i see you on some ad for
something they were pimping you as a
guest
uh some 501st they i did a 501st
live stream today i talked about jar jar
binks for an hour
that's it they were like super fan
and fat man producer
i was like why don't they pump the bar
because i thought for sure it would say
scum and villainy cantina owner but yeah
i'm sure there was something political
about that
because jen mentioned that too she's
like
oh i noticed they don't pump the bar on
on this
well we'll pop the bar scum and villainy
cantina is open right now kids
on hollywood boulevard in hollywood
california and within three
short weeks it sounds like me and mark
are going to behind the be behind the
bar
doing what we do right there but does
that mean you can't
go visit doesn't mean you can't go get
[ __ ]
drunk drown your sorrows amongst good
geeky people you'll never get in a fight
you think you'll ever get punched in the
face in that [ __ ] bar
[ __ ] you're gonna get punched in the
heart
there's one guy who got punched in the
face i'll tell this story i shouldn't
but
there's one guy who got punched in the
face before i just had this whole pitch
and you make it
alive it was one time it was
at midnight literally at midnight as
christmas eve turned into christmas day
and two dudes walked into the bar
looking for trouble
and punched some poor nerd in the face
and knocked him off his barstool he was
just sitting there doodling by himself
and our bartender jumped over the bar to
protect him
it was crazy it was the craziest thing
i've ever seen
wasn't a camera he just came in to
[ __ ] hit somebody it was just
two people looking to cause trouble and
we were like the only place
open on hollywood boulevard that night
somebody's [ __ ] in his stocking is what
happened
i'm putting a coal in a big bad way uh
i also got i'm gonna go i'll guess i
guess it's good for the image jc wants
you to know there's always a chance you
could get punched in the face
once in four years captain america will
leap across the bar
and save your ass i'll also say i got a
tweet this morning uh it was just sent
to me usually when
i'm i get tweets it's it's all three of
us
uh i got a tweet it was just sent to me
from liquidskinner on twitter and he
says
the bamf thing is so obnoxious i've had
to give up listening to the podcast
i was like everybody else loves it
but we found the one guy yeah you gotta
have a lot of hate in your heart to be
like
not only feel that way but to also let
you know
let you know personally he didn't dial
me and mark in man like
to see cosign he was like hey banff man
you ruined the show please i can't watch
anymore
i told him i said joe don't worry we'll
be back in the bar in a few weeks come
back and visit us
he's one of them [ __ ] bamfests
you don't need that in your life
all right let's hit it uh chris gerard
if kevin and mark were to do a comic
book psa
what would the message be and which
superhero would you have deliver it
i'm doing a comic book psa is it a psa
about
comics or is it just using comics too no
yeah it's like what captain america did
in the bonus features or what used to be
at the end of every
masters in the universe um this is kind
of cruel but i would have batman
promoting the theater district
it's like he'd really have to believe in
it you know to be like
the theater it's worth seeing your
parents killed over here
as batman so it was very like
that's how you reopen broadway right
there that's gotham's i love new york
campaign
you should go see kinky boots or uh
hamilton
or uh that waitress show the theater's
great
i was a big fan of jagged little pill
i'd risk an ant for that movie
a book of mormon i'd risk my parents
again
[Laughter]
uh all right uh that's me what about you
um i am trying not to say
the punisher doing an ad for gun control
but i just said it that's good
robert mills in the comments section
through in a tagline for the batman
theater campaign ready
gotham theater district it's to die for
fun for the whole family oh my god
that's too funny bring your pal
uh santiago heck says uh batman's other
line is
people are just dying to get back to the
theater
people now i'm gonna get criticized for
not doing batman at all
you're like that don't sound like
[ __ ] batman yeah we know theater of
the mind
batman's favorite show
uh phantom of the opera cats
that that joke is so sweet and innocent
kid you can go play that for your
grandma even your great grandma
she'd be like oh he's a funny boy that
kevin james he's a funny boy
bruce osno and chat says the tagline is
bring your family
leave an orphan
all right man uh what uh what do we got
next jc that was fun
you just irritated one more person who's
like i quit this pogba
they're not listening already though
that's the i can call him out because
he's not listening
let's see uh rich but not wealthy
uh says if kevin and mark were
superheroes
what would he have what would they have
on their jersey
on their jersey costumes uh and they he
says a blunt is
too easy so what would your superhero
costumes look like
i mean kids this is a no-brainer i did
it for like a decade i wore my face my
own
face on my [ __ ] jersey
the bob hawks logo for years i literally
wore
that on my chest were variations various
pictures of myself on my chest if it
wasn't on a hockey jersey
later on it was a t-shirt so my
superhero outfit would probably
have you know [ __ ] my face on if not
that
that bob hawks logo um yeah i
i'm uh i'm a brand [ __ ] and
there came a day i don't know when it
was but there came a day where i was
like
why am i wearing a star wars t-shirt i
should be [ __ ] promoting my [ __ ] and
that's
and in the beginning i used to think oh
it's tacky to wear your own [ __ ] and i'm
like
how can you ask anybody else to buy one
of your t-shirts if you're not willing
to wear it and [ __ ] so
brand management department i know it
wouldn't be good to help me keep a
secret identity but
i'd wear my own face on my chest
i'm going to shoot him twice but
and but that's the thing just like
[ __ ] frank miller wrote in the dark
knight returns mark
because i put my face on my chest i put
a bulletproof [ __ ] target
under it because that face is the target
like i'm like what do you think i'm
insane putting a bright yellow light on
my chest
i give them something to shoot at so
that's the [ __ ] philosophy
input yeah i'm stealing frank miller's
philosophy from dark knight returns
which was still to this day captures my
imagination that somebody
bothered to explain the yellow oval that
was his explanation he was like
why do you think i [ __ ] wore yellow
so that people would fire right at my
[ __ ] chest which he's got a big
bulletproof plate under it for and [ __ ]
such a great idea so anyway i'd steal
that idea because as we all know
i'm not very original i just rehash [ __ ]
and that's a great thing to rehash and
be so tasty second time around
nice uh i feel like
okay i would do uh the
skull from hamlet poor uric
his skull and the cross bones are two
fountain pens
oh that's a good one that's a good
hockey jersey what [ __ ] that's a good
mark bernard
shirt to make next there you go
somebody's looking for an idea or you
bring a writer uh
artist on draw that man but there you go
that's your [ __ ]
your insignia right there that'll be the
logo for my production company
yeah yeah man so the idea is
it's york skull like alaska york and
this
crossbone pens are two writing pens yeah
and it's called the i love booty
productions
how far does the pirate theme go mark
movies so good movies movies what is it
it's like the smuckers
with a name like bootylicious it's got
to be good these movies have got to be
good
um i like that that was [ __ ] dope man
people aren't getting maybe the people
aren't getting the most uh
well thought out answers but they're
true who answers
we're not we're not uh we're not lying
here and and he just came up with a
brand new shirt that you'll be able to
buy where do you make your shirts
yeah embattledclothing.com there you go
get them working on that shirt
i bet it happens before the jeff's kiss
shirt [ __ ] up
i asked jordan this week again i was
like hey man cause somebody tweeted me
they're like
am i gonna see a jeff shirt [ __ ] uh
jeff's kiss shirt before i die
and so i forwarded it to jordan to be
like hey is this guy ever going to see a
jeff's kiss shirt before he died she
said they're ordered they're ordered so
hopefully next year he's like is he sick
it's a time table here hopefully soon
within the next two weeks
or something boy will they be worth the
wait poor nate i asked him to draw it
like [ __ ] a year ago
we've both been trying to make this
shirt happen for so long
um anyway man last question
irritating somebody and losing
i bring you back to do what we need you
to do give us the third
and when i face a third i don't mean
turd give us the third
do you know in canada
i think it's canada they don't call the
ad the third a d
because it sounds too close to the turd
ad i think that's in america too
that's where the term second second came
from so there's a first a d
the second a d there used to be a third
a d
but it was sounds too close to turn a d
so they changed it to second second
what's with the [ __ ] super sensitive
third ads like
we haven't outlawed the word third any
place else in the world
there's still a third floor there's
still a third base but
these guys are like it sounds like turd
because it was known bully evil knievel
mark who walk around
in the 70s and call them all third ads
and people like
evil i don't know that's not true i also
feel like if anybody was going to be
sensitive about their title it should be
the associate producer
the ass prod
the [ __ ] best boy is still just going
to be the best boy
even as a grown ass man or a woman
indeed
you're the best boy but no these [ __ ]
ads
are super precious about the potential
it's like what should we name the boy
somebody that doesn't run with fart
bart
with that all said here the second
second question ladies and gentlemen
uh let's see tr morris wants to know
uh what is your favorite movie sequence
that is scored to a rock song
so the example he gives is any of the
numerous martin scorsese
uh things scored to uh rolling stones
um yeah no doubt um i'll let marco first
i'm always hogging the mic
um i i
think i think it's gonna be
uh a long long time till touchdown
brings me back i'm yet to
find i'm not the man i think i am
at oh oh no no no
um it's steelers wheel stuck in the
middle with you
in uh in reservoir dogs
when uh when michael madden said cuts a
dude's ear off
like i think that that the the song is
great i mean
of the people who do needle drops as
part of their score
it's scorsese and it's and it's [ __ ]
tarantino
are very high up on that hill of people
who do it incredibly well
and i think that's that's my favorite
version of that
so yeah that's a legit answer that's
good
um for an opening credit sequence uh
i think the use of come and get your
love
at the start of uh guardians was about
as pitch perfect as the needle drop use
of a song
goes um but let me think in terms of a
song in a movie where the
scene is cut to it this is a lame
example but one of my favorite examples
of this
still influences me to to this day
is a episode of moonlighting
where david addison was following
maddie madeleine hayes dad
because she thought he was having an
affair
so like david was casing him and they
used the song
or it was about him casing his own
father
i can't remember if somebody's i think
it was maddie's father because they also
they did an episode with david's father
and that was paul cervino
ironically enough as the father of uh
bruce willis
and um that was when his dad was getting
married i think the story line was that
david
slept with his wife like i was drunk at
a bar we had sex
the other one when maddie thought her
dad was having a fair
david addison follows him around los
angeles and they play
uh the papa was a rolling stone
and it's just well cut to it that's such
a great song so much so that i
stole that idea and uh i wrote a thing
recently
um for uh hbo max
and uh like i i rarely write music into
something but i wrote that into it for
the same kind of
cat and mouse sequence or somebody
doesn't realize they're being
somebody doing detective work sequence
um but that's probably not a very
popular example to use
so let me think let me think
hmm
i mean this probably don't count either
because it's not really cut
well maybe um tonight is what it means
to be young
at the end of streets of fire you know
it's well cut as [ __ ] it's literal
storytelling with songs and you're
also seeing the climax of the movie and
the hero spoilers walk away from the
woman he loves
yet again as he did years before and
they're star-crossed and she is
committed to her life and he has to go
back to his but you know they'll meet
again one day and they never [ __ ] did
we never got to see ella name again i
would watch a [ __ ] sequel that movie
set now with
diane lane the age she is oh hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah man bring back michael power
get right back to them streets of fire
willem dafoe's still alive
amy madigan's still around you could
literally rick moranis is here
we still have time mark tonight
and tonight is what it means to be young
indeed um many examples
i also feel like uh shout out to thor
ragnarok's use
of immigrant song yes
absolutely um look it's grotesque i was
gonna
name a number of times i've done it like
with tusk i think i did it pretty well
but regardless
you're absolutely [ __ ] right the
immigrants ah
twice twice two times yeah could you
imagine it's like amazing
you get [ __ ] well once but then twice
the same song um that was a great
question yielded some great [ __ ]
results man
i dropped mine uh the touch
in transformers the movie 1986.
look at you playing to the crowd well
done man you're trying to win back that
guy
but also i really liked and
because i i got to see the backside of
it um
in janus island bob reboot the the movie
scene
i enjoyed it was you and me and
um and liz and jordan
and uh the music supervisor going
through
because we we couldn't use bad medicine
again
going through alternates and i was
dropping my 80s knowledge and completely
outed myself as an 80s hairband
fan that blew up his mind so
uh i i enjoyed i enjoyed that
and i also remember you cutting that
scene and then like sending it
to me and then like the version of the
song was different
so we had to recut it remember that yeah
that's right because i cut to the
original version of the song but the
song that we got wasn't the original it
was
like cheaper because it was the
re-record but because of that
it was like off in places for the edit
and stuff
um but yeah we got a good price on that
uh whereas
tusk cost a quarter of a million dollars
just for the [ __ ] song
so you i added the [ __ ] out of that
montage
every beat i'm like make this [ __ ] work
um uh i would also point out
the closing number of uh the muppet
movie
for the like you know life's like a
movie write your own
ending that whole song that leads up to
that [ __ ]
but that's not cutting a movie to a song
now we're just now i'm just named
songs i like yeah um goodbye horses
oh [ __ ] it's so memorable right yeah
don't forget that [ __ ]
yeah one of the best the most memorable
uses of a [ __ ] needle drop in movie
history
and you know not because it's like oh
it's so warm and wonderful it's like
nope um and also and not because like
the dude tucks his dick back that was
just hot
um it's more about that there's someone
screaming downstairs like you can't hear
that song without thinking of like
somebody trapped in a well like [ __ ]
with a
you know a dog and a [ __ ] chicken
bone and a bucket and a [ __ ]
and you know waiting to die at the hands
of a guy who's going to turn you into a
skin
like that could you think could you
imagine if they'd use
like don't worry be happy and they would
have ruined that song forever
whatever song they chose would have been
just destroyed
no doubt man no doubt um wait so we
answered
the answered the these questions three
that means the show's at an end isn't it
mark
snicked snick got all three
we started at uh about 4 30ish and it's
now
uh like 12 o'clock uh west coast time no
it's only
we've only been going for like two and a
half hours but [ __ ] well
yes two and a half hours so that's
enough that's enough
it's a decent-sized show now we're just
like
overly [ __ ] at this point they're
like you've already come a few times and
you're like oh just finish
up already fine yeah now just you're
rubbing yourself raw at this point
yeah we're sorry we'll just we'll we'll
we'll come up we'll pull out and finish
off over here
sorry we'll go in the shower yeah
looking like old men who have had this
problem
uh ladies and gentlemen we hope that
you've enjoyed yourself here
uh with us on fat man beyond it was a
tough week to go without you guys last
week and gals of course
but uh great to be with with you back
here this week uh
don't forget uh geeked week
on netflix is happening this week so
you're gonna get a chance to see
some things that me and mark worked on a
long time we've been talking about for a
long time
uh you've seen some still images now
you're going to see images move real
fast that's how animation works you guys
absolutely right but don't forget that's
you'll see that and i can't wait but
we might see some sandman [ __ ] like if
we're showing some motu [ __ ] maybe
they're showing some sandman [ __ ] so
they got some cool shows listed
that they're dropping a bunch of like
panels for and and previews for
so it's happening i think it starts on
thursday
all over netflix geeks social media so
if you're a motu cat you're curious
about motu
that's where you're gonna get a first
look this week kids
one of the best things i saw on the
internet this past week
was uh neil gaiman responding to people
who were
uh unhappy with some of the sandman
casting announcements
namely that uh there's a black actress
playing
death people got mad at that people got
shitty about that
and so somebody goes
as one can imagine people got shitty
about it they got mad about the human
torch
you know when michael b jordan played
the human torch for that minute that
everyone forgot about because then he
became killmonger and stuff
i'm sure somebody bumped into that i
didn't at all the only thing i thought
when i saw that name i was like was that
is that mary anne or mary wasn't there
another woman actress named jean
baptiste or
marianne jim baptiste i was wondering if
that was her kid if there was any
relation whatsoever but
she could be she looks fantastic and
like you know you
look she got beautiful eyes and that's
what you want in [ __ ] death and stuff
but like
the one that like uh surprised me
unfortunately
sadly that did not surprise me we've
seen that kind of reaction before
the reaction that surprised me though
was when they went after his casting of
despair and you know
they were they like neil was like you
know she's been non-binary or
not she that character has been they
have been non-binary
since i created that character and then
i remembered reading that character
and that was a big point of it like that
it was this kind of genderless
and so um he he like
you know the guy was like i was doing
this
[ __ ] in the 90s kids like
yeah my favorite was some some guy came
at him for casting a
black actresses death and his logic was
um it would be as as if you just you
cast a white actress to play mazzakin
which is a character that's on lucifer
and uh
and he was like yeah man uh mazakin was
white
in the comics we changed to be black for
the show clearly you've never read the
books
but thanks for stopping by i hope you
enjoy the show
it's always fun to watch people try and
um you know
neil splain to neil his own work
nielsen um it's just i mean and
look as a look i bought issue one of
sandman
off the rack cover price you saw i've
been on the ride
since the get-go took a chance on the
weird cover and [ __ ] looked like a
[ __ ] photograph more than
artwork or whatever the [ __ ] and found
discovered
fell into a world that not only uh stole
my
heart enriched my work later on you
don't get to dogma unless i [ __ ] trip
over you know sandman earlier than i
wound up right in that movie so
um i've been that's a long way saying
i've been waiting forever to see a
sandman
anything and i don't bump into a single
[ __ ] piece of the casting you know
when that cass gwendolyn christie is
lucifer i was like that [ __ ] rocks
give it to me
oh yeah like i'm happy with all of it
i don't bump into [ __ ] any of it and
i can't wait who's playing
it's not somebody who's super famous
who's playing morpheus right yeah i
don't remember
thomas boy in the podcast but not in the
tv show correct yeah yeah
um did you see that [ __ ] patton
oswalt is matthew the raven yeah yeah
and the story behind that was adorable
that like
at one point patton you know got himself
online at some san francisco bookstore
to buy a copy of like doll's house
signed by neil gaiman
and uh and now he's like yeah 30 years
later or whatever the hell it is i get
to play
[ __ ] matthew the raven this is you
know who can tell
how life is going to work itself out the
gorsey pointed out
uh wisely people got mad about keaton's
batman he's absolutely right kids there
was no
internet in 1988 or 1989 but in 1988
[ __ ] it might even been late 87
when they announced the casting of
michael keaton as
as batman holy heavens
were people [ __ ] angry there was no
internet
and it was people were so angry it broke
the non-existent internet
and they were like mr mom as [ __ ]
batman what are you nuts and this week
we all
[ __ ] our jeans over a photo of michael
keaton's bat insignia with a little
[ __ ] blue flash on it so
yeah there's a litany of casting uh
announcements that that brought ire from
fans hugh jackman
as logan as wolverine was greeted by
he's too [ __ ] tall like it should be
bob hoskins not [ __ ] hugh jackman
i mean tom cruise bob hoskins a fine
actor but
it's not my that's not the wolverine i
would have liked to have seen yeah
like tom cruise as as the vampire lestat
and
rice hated that casting until she saw
the movie and
everybody was kind of won over like we
we do this
every couple of years true ear
ie pointed out same goes for heath
ledger that's right
here in our lifetimes kids like we saw
[ __ ] when they cast heath ledger
people like knight's tale
what the [ __ ] and he turned in one of
the greatest
not just joker performances but were not
just comic book movie performances one
of the
most captivating performances ever
[ __ ] recorded on film he went on
oscar for it i don't know if that
matters to anybody but
yeah he got an oscar i mean sadly it was
after he passed but he got one
because the performance was so like
[ __ ] great um
yeah that's nuts man
um all right is that it
that's it now we're just we're just
humping
we are that's what we do on the show we
hump
we can't hump remember that scene from
[ __ ]
carlito's way and it was what's his name
it's uh migo
it is it is
he comes to see him and he's in a
wheelchair and he's wearing a [ __ ]
recording device
he's like i can't i can't i can't dance
i can't
hump
and i think he was like you know he had
like an accent and stuff like that i
mean but so did
it was an albuquerque a cuban
and he's not
um well those were different times
in a world where you could cast [ __ ]
uh
what's his name john wayne as genghis
khan hollywood's
i was long list of dodgy
casting choices not us kids
not us i saw your cast man [ __ ] looks
looks [ __ ] we talked about in the
other episode too but yeah man
it's uh cast right there we got a couple
of
roles still left uh left to be filled
but um
we're aiming high higher than we have
any right to aim but
worth it worth it you know people who
know people
know people who know people don't forget
kids fly over to kickstarter
pun intended so you can look up splinter
short
indeed mark's first directorial his
effort um a couple bucks away from
hitting the
200 000 mark where uh mark then
uh just goes snyder uncut
all over his i do i will hold court
in scum and villainy we will sell
tickets for said affair
and you can watch me just [ __ ] put my
knee pads on and get sloppy
bald bulldozer wrote tmz headline kevin
smith says viggo mortensen
that's the movie line kids i can't
pump
um all right there it is there it is
kids we hope you had a good time have a
great
rest of your weekend we'll be back to do
this next weekend
uh next weekend we'll be talking about
loki
yes we'll be talking about the masters
of the universe revelation whatever it
is that is seen in netflix geeks week
and we'll be talking about anything else
that matters to you
me him everybody everybody
everybody everybody
there's some kids it's all the blues
brothers right there uh
with give it up for uh our our banff man
himself jump in here banff man and take
your [ __ ] plaudits
jc ladies and gentlemen he's got that
there's scum and villainy cantina which
we're gonna get back to one day but you
ain't got to wait for us they're open
right now
go get liquored up go get liquor liquor
or lick him don't matter
at the scumming villain cantina happy
pride month everybody
what are you how are you guys
celebrating pride month at the bar
uh we we're not allowed to do anything
because
of covid so we are we are there
uh we're stealing alcohol yes
but with open arms and welcoming
everybody in
but that's we do that every day so
that's true um what do you mean because
kobe you're not allowed to do functions
we're not allowed to do any functions
we're not you're basically not allowed
to do anything
and we're so like i just got a message
we had a line out the door
before we opened we had a line to get in
today so
look at that [ __ ] look at your [ __ ]
the first world life [ __ ] you're
talking about in your basement here
while you're [ __ ] making your
millions in your goddamn bar you're like
robert kirkman and jeff the millions yes
uh give it up for jc ladies and
gentlemen he's the one that uh
pumps us pumps you up
into uh your [ __ ] living rooms me and
mark and [ __ ]
there ain't no show uh without the guy
in the bat cave look at him we didn't
even comment on that that's a [ __ ]
sweet background man
could you imagine if you showed a
picture of that to yourself
like in childhood like one day this is
gonna be this is what you do for a
living
what you sit in front of dumbass
backgrounds and crack
jokes this is [ __ ] that's it
um uh give it up for the great uh mark
bernardin ladies and gentlemen thank you
sir
uh thank you to our uh our sponsors
we're the hosts
uh the good folks at uh manscaped.com
ladies and gentlemen that's the
lawnmower 4.0
shear your nuts for heaven's sakes uh as
well as uh the good folks at keeps.com
don't forget their promo codes and i'm
sure there's a link somewhere in chat
that'll get you there more easily than
me saying that [ __ ] to you over and over
again
that ladies and gentlemen is fat man
beyond for this week i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next time same
fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss
you